okay uh this morning you know I wake up
of course we had the news and I decide
I'm going to do a segment about the
Epstein conspiracy being confirmed yeah
because uh the Wall Street Journal
reported that Bill Bill Gates was being
blackmailed by Epstein to try and get
money out of him which is but a keyhole
into the whole Epstein conspiracy but
basically confirms what we all believed
is likely true Epstein was blackmailing
powerful individuals and trying to
control them through
threatening to leak information on there
let's just call it adult Private Affairs
now the Wall Street Journal says it
appears to be this way but then outright
say their sources say the intention of
this communication was to Blackmail Bill
Gates I'll take it it may be just a
single grain of sand that in in the in
the evidentiary file of epste Epstein
was doing this but now we know at least
in this one instance he was I think it's
fair to say in all likelihood this is
how he was doing everything he was doing
the question that becomes is he the
Mastermind or is he the messenger so
we're going to talk about that Boyd we
got a lot of stuff to talk about uh
Trump's 2025 agendas a lot of people are
really excited but before we get into
all that my friends head over to
castbrew.com yo check it out I got a bag
of Appalachian nights right here we got
this one in and uh this is our coffee
company if you want to push back against
will corporations and support one of our
companies support a company that doesn't
hate you go to castbrew.com buy your
coffee from us I recommend Appalachian
nights or rise with Roberto Jr our
Roberto Jr light rail is just too
insanely popular
you can also join the cast Brew Coffee
club and get three different bags every
single month and support companies that
don't hate you we really do appreciate
it I gotta be honest I uh uh uh I've
brewed up some Appalachian nights this
morning it was so good I just slammed
the coffee normally I drink it very
slowly but it's just man is it good
stuff so I really do appreciate all your
support don't forget to head over to
timcast.com click join us
to watch our members only a members only
uncensored shows now uh we're hanging
out Dan bongino today who's got to leave
right on the Mark at the end of the show
so we did a pre-show with him which will
be available right when we wrap this up
we'll upload it so you can watch that
uncensored show we talked a lot about uh
talked about a lot of really cool stuff
so uh smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends if you really do like it and
think we make a difference and as I
already mentioned joining us tonight we
are it is an honor and a privilege we
have Dan bongino man you don't miss that
pre-show although I have to apologize
yeah I was it was good but there were
quite a few f-bombs so I'm really sorry
that the parents with kids at home but
that was a lot of fun you got the energy
going man you got me like flying right
into this here yeah it was great we
talked about war elections uh but we
wanted to save some of the best stuff
for going live so I think most people
know who you are but uh do you want to
just provide a simple introduction yeah
so I was a cop and then I was a secret
service agent for a little while I'm
gonna sum this up and like like 10 and
then I got tired of all those things I
said I want to go do something or try to
get a medical school it didn't work ran
for office almost one but didn't win
Horseshoes and Hand Grenades did a hit
on Fox wound up with a radio show and a
podcast and then just flew up to meet
the great Tim pool today there we go
appreciate it it's nothing I hate more
than long intros you ever go to give a
speech and they have this here's Tim
Paul and they're reading for like 20
minutes I'm like dude wrap it up wrap it
up I send them one sentence uh here to
speak is Dan bongino uh he's a really
nice guy and he's got something to say
Thank you so there you go perfect this
is sum it up how you doing everyone I am
uh Phil Avanti the lead singer from the
heavy metal band All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
and I'm here with my friend again
Crossland
yo welcome back baby thanks for having
me how long was it was it two weeks yeah
I think so man and I'll be here for a
couple days and then I'm gonna be out
for a few more I'm gonna go uh take a
little short rest and go see Tool uh on
this coming week I'm very excited oh
yeah oh yeah they got some we play Tool
a lot during my Maynard that and then
some of that stuff is epic one song just
blows me away though every time
no no no no no no damn it I don't know
see the thing is with a band like tool
they have so many great songs to start
start listening off you're just gonna
miss dude H is so hot man my roommate in
college would get drunk and punch
and then he got had four kids he was
like getting ready to become a father
and he could just see it him going
through it right on yeah welcome back
Ian thanks Tim thanks for having me and
that Appalachian nights is delicious 46
and two oh that's a good song oh dude
epic yes that song man that blows me
away I would like to cover that sometime
that's a really hot song songs now I
know it's not tool But A Perfect Circle
Judith I think is one of the greatest
songs ever written yes the the the the
lyrics the story the guitar on that it's
just Man Maynard Legend I I love Tunes
I'm a big big music guy I was in the
country and stuff but tool blows it up
you know who was like an underrated band
too
my your show up already man
not like we had all this stuff to talk
about we'll get to FC there folks but
System of a Down yeah yeah so like other
those guys man they tore it uh toxicity
I was just listening to that a couple
days ago man that beat that it's like
that that bass and that drama oh man so
badass I wish I could sing man but I
can't I just went to the Morgan Wallen
concert the last one before his voice
got all busted up I was so wrecked I had
like five white claws it was the only
like I don't drink white cloth but it
was the only alcoholic beverage where
there was no lime and they wouldn't let
you go in with like five or six at a
time so I had to keep going out so I was
drinking he's like tall boy white
clothes man totally obliterated complete
blast and like people are coming up to
me like and it's loud I can't hear
anything because I'm half deaf anyway
for my time in the Secret Service with
that thing jamming my ear and people are
like hey bro you show we love you so I'm
like I'm just listening to Tunes man but
I whatever you're saying I really
appreciate it I had a total blast man
music's my thing man right on we got
search hanging out too yeah I am hanging
out wearing my hat that said apps needed
an Epson himself just for the occasion
so uh yeah let's get started here we go
so this is this is a this is stories
this is not this is it from The Wall
Street Journal take a look at this
picture we got Epstein and Bill Gates
Right There Jeffrey Epstein appeared to
threaten Bill Gates over Microsoft
co-founders affair with Russian bridge
player it is the lightest smallest grain
of sand effectively confirming I I
believe confirming the the conspiracy
the conspiracy theory that Epstein was
blackmailing powerful individuals but
they outright say it in here they say in
2017 Epstein emailed Gates and asked him
to be reimbursed for the cost of a
coding course for this young woman
according to people familiar with the
matter now the issue here is why would
Epstein contact Bill Gates about a young
woman he had an affair with in secret
except to say I know you had the affair
I want the money
I know you had the affair they even go
on to say the intention was to Blackmail
uh Bill Gates in this so let me just
read the say
Jeffrey Epstein discovered that Bill
Gates had an affair with a Russian
bridge player and later appeared to use
his knowledge to threaten one of the
world's richest men according to people
familiar with the matter the Microsoft
co-founder met the woman around 2012
2012 2010 when she was in her 20s abstin
met her in 2013 and later paid for her
to attend software coding school the
email came into the convicted sex
offender had struggled and failed to
persuade gates to participate in a
multi-billion dollar charitable fund
that Epstein tried to establish with JP
Morgan Chase and that whole story right
there sounds like more blackmail he went
to JP Morgan and said I want to get a
bunch of the richest people in the world
to invest a hundred million dollars into
this fund and then I get paid Millions
out of it they say the implication
behind the message according to people
who viewed it was that Epstein could
reveal the affair if Gates didn't keep
up an association between the two men
now is this why Bill Gates divorced his
wife yes you think so absolutely I think
that I think that when you're dealing
with people that are that wealthy and in
the positions that uh uh the people were
in the people they went to Epstein's
Island the positions that they held
these people are not motivated by money
you know a couple million here a couple
million there Bill Gates isn't going to
notice but if you threaten to tell his
wife that he's been you know porking
some kid
that'll go ahead and get some compliance
and obedience out of them and that's
what it's I think that that's the reason
why Epstein's dead and I think that's
the reason why the list never came out
the people that have been to Epstein
Island because they're all probably
scummy people that have a lot that had a
lot of dirt or that I've seen had a lot
of dirt on them and that's what kept
them you know in line I think that there
are there are very powerful people that
have a lot of dirt on people with a lot
of money I couldn't help but notice in
that I think it was a PBS interview with
Bill Gates you see that one where he's
like well he's dead so you know I always
say but but here's the thing when he
goes he says she says did was did you
learn in a lesson here and he goes well
he's dead now so you know you always got
to be careful and he's like holding back
a smile and I'm like it's kind of weird
in later context to hear that Bill Gates
was being blackmailed by Jeffrey Epstein
and you go back to this interview where
he said he was asked if he learned a
lesson and seemingly for no reason he
says he's dead and so you got to be
careful as if to actually imply if you
screw with me
you know what happens how did this email
come out with this data it's a Wall
Street Wall Street Journal reporting so
someone leaked it to the okay someone
they they it sounds like they actually
talked to people uh
who know Bill Gates and even got a quote
for from a spokeswoman for Bill Gates oh
they say Mr Gates met with Epstein
solely for philanthropic purposes having
failed repeatedly to draw Mr Gates
Beyond these matters Epstein tried
unsuccessfully to leverage a past
relationship to threaten Mr Gates a
spokesman four Gates confirming Epstein
was blackmailing him yeah
man this Epstein thing I got a lot to
talk this Epstein thing really kind of
it kind of like it's like a tick
burrowing under my skin I get a call
let's go yeah this is gonna get hair you
guys ready yes
this is like live YouTube you ready for
this I don't know if you guys right I
get a call about four years ago it's
from let's say a friend prior line of
work thing right guy says listen and
this guy who calls me is an
unimpeachable Source this guy's not like
some ham and egg or tomato can guy
throwing out some theory about a UFO he
saw 72 years ago whatever this is like a
legit no-nonsense guy
guy you trust with your you know wife
kid in car right
he says you know I got sent on a
temporary assignment once and on that
assignment I got sent out with the wcd
detail William Clinton uh William
Clinton detail
and uh I knew this guy well and he says
dan I I gotta share this with someone
he's like go on a plane and Bill you
know Clinton gets on the plane with this
guy and it turns out later that guy's
Epstein now this guy I'm talking to this
Source he don't know who to you know
Jeffrey Epstein is he's just getting on
the plane doing the thing the whole you
know protection gig right
he says I get on the plane and there's
these girls who are obviously not of age
who are on this plane they're clearly
young these are not women these are
girls
and he says I see Clinton might
disappear into the back
with he goes I don't know what happened
I'm not saying what happened because all
I know is he disappeared and these girls
were back there or whatever and he said
they landed the next stop wherever it
was
and he goes up to the boss on the detail
and he says I I ain't getting back on
this plane because he's remember he's a
temp he's not so he's not used to like
whatever Clinton was up to with the
whole Shenanigans thing and this guy is
clear as the driven snowman he don't
want to mess around with this he says
whatever just happened back there like I
don't want any piece of it you know they
sent him home they sent that guy home
and he would never he's never tempted at
detail again now remember all those
blackberries on that detail here's
here's where the story gets super weird
the guy tells me
what is it months or a couple weeks
later when you lose property in the
Secret Service and email goes out to say
like hey I lost this phone and it goes
it gets logged into ncic or whatever it
is and everybody knows so basically if
you find this guy's gun God forbid his
phone it's now effectively stolen
property right all of a sudden all the
blackberries on that detail
for the agent to start showing up like
oh this guy lost his BlackBerry holy
wow that's so crazy how'd that
happen I'm like no he says yes he says
it was the craziest thing like oh look
agent Joey Bag of Donuts missing
Blackberry missing black bear this is
around the whole time like the Clinton
thing's going on so fast forward this
story right he tells me that about a
year and a half after that I'm in a
green room at Fox and I'm not gonna say
who because they didn't give me
permission to share it but well the
short story but not who they are says
you know Epstein's a an intelligence
asset for people in the Middle East
right I'm like no I didn't know that I'm
like you sure that's
the person let's say is like I'm
absolutely sure that that he's either
very witting or unwitting asset
intelligence asset meaning
his plane and that Island the cameras
there's a big assumption out there that
these videotapes were exclusively in the
custody of Epstein that's a huge mistake
the reason they wanted this story to go
away is because there's an assumption
like oh yeah Epstein had him no he
wasn't the only one who had him
according to his Source these assets
that's why this blackmail story makes so
much sense which Middle Eastern
countries they are I don't know but this
person who's a very very good reporter I
mean Aces right swore Epstein was either
a witting or unwitting intelligence
asset and they may have had his plane
wired up and they're the ones who have
all this stuff so the point is to sum it
up
how how do you know some of these
countries aren't going to some of these
power plays who aren't making decisions
because hey you wouldn't want this video
out there right how do you know 100 I
mean that let's let's get personal with
Mr Gates though if this is a story of an
adult man having adult relations with an
adult female outside of his marriage is
it the biggest deal in the world that
needs to be made public you know what I
mean what what I'm interested in is the
underage stuff the creepos that evidence
coming out I'm worried that they're
doing this with the Bill Gates thing as
like red meat like oh look oh oh yeah
and it's like it's not a criminal issue
it's a personal Scandal it's like oh wow
Bill Gates looks bad but what about the
Maxwell stuff what about the actual
Client List I don't think we should be
satisfied by what we're hearing and we
should obviously want more I think
you're totally right I think that the
actual crimes that they committed while
they are bad like I don't think that's
the worst thing that's going on I think
the like the things that they're being
blackmailed to cover up is probably
worse than the crimes they committed
well as bad as they are you know well I
was gonna say I think
the stuff that's that they're being
blackmailed to cover up probably is not
as bad as what they're doing yeah in
series is that what you're saying yes
yes right so like we hear a story about
you know prince Andrew and uh Virginia
and you're alive wow this guy should be
in trouble for that it's like what did
he do to try and hide that yes because
I'm I'm willing about a lot of these
wealthy guys did something 10 times more
evil or supported some real evil stuff
what does he know that someone else
knows that he knows that they're
threatening to go public about his let's
just you know molesting children you
know let's put it this way
you you you blackmail someone like Bill
Gates into giving up millions of dollars
to Epstein who then uses that money for
his trafficking purposes and that is the
the bigger problem these guys who are
like oh no my Affair could be exposed
better fund Epstein that's the crazy
thing here don't you find it weird too
that nobody seems to know what Epstein
really did no one else right it's like
oh they said he was a hedge fund guys
really what's the fun like the Joey Bag
of Donuts hedge funding nobody can seem
to dig up what this which brings it back
to your point like where was was that
what was happening was it some circular
like hey it'd be a shame if this got out
oh look a donation to your little thing
which he then uses to do I mean that
would be a really sick story even worse
than the original if they were funding
this stuff I think they were I think
like how else does this guy have half a
billion dollars a private island and
jets
I think the milk the asset thing makes
sense because one of the questions that
comes up from this is was he a puppet or
was he The Mastermind and I don't think
some former High School teacher was The
Mastermind I think he was the puppet
yeah I I don't know for sure I mean it's
an interesting there's interesting
questions around that but I I would lean
towards I'm Betty was I bet he was a
puppet and somebody else got away with
it oh yeah especially if this Middle
Eastern asset conversation holds water
that he's they're basically laundering
their money through Epstein and getting
him an island and a place to live and
funding his operation and then he's
getting Bill Clinton on an airplane and
getting him recorded having sex with
some girl that's not his wife well he
didn't do that he met this woman
apparently and then found out about the
affair and tried using that as leverage
against gates from this story We it
would seem the picture they're trying to
paint is Bill Gates never did the more
extreme things people are concerned
about that's why I'm like is this them
placating us hey leaked them a little
bit so that it seems like Bill Gates's
worst thing is that he doesn't wife it's
called a limited hangout as opposed to
letting it all hang out a limited
hangout is where they only give you a
when like there's bad things going on
they tell you the truth about a little
thing or smaller things so that way you
can say oh we've told you all the stuff
blah blah but in reality they're doing
it to distract you from the actual big
thing a little bit hang out versus
letting it all hang out and then when
someone says Bill Gates was on Epstein's
plane they go oh we know about that you
know and then and then I've seen
blackmail over that woman but she was
she was an adult I mean people from
people aren't talking about or people
often forget the connections that
Epstein has with politicians the
clintons the you know and and that's I
think that probably has a significant
amount of substance as well even if like
Bill Clinton wasn't banging the little
girls on Epstein's Islands it's the
connection that he has in the influence
look at how many people were just
dumping money into the Clinton
Foundation when Hillary Clinton was was
running and then it just like
disappeared and evaporated after she
lost no one really questions what was
going on with with that money and with
the Clinton Foundation I mean I it
probably still exists but the
connections between you know politicians
and Epstein and you know I think that
that's something worth looking into and
it blows my mind that you guys We're not
gonna get it listen to this story right
like what dirtbags these people who run
this country and essentially run the
glow bar do you ever seen so like what's
scumbags like how do you get on a plane
with a girl that looks 14 and a dude
disappears in the back and you're like
hey you got popcorn really like right
what kind of sick run this place we're
talking about business Titans and nobody
ratted this guy out nobody was like Hey
man that looks kind of suspicious what
kind of losers are running this place
wait you want to Buckley say I'd rather
have you know the first hundred names in
the phone book than these people who run
the country nice but he's so right yeah
I mean you look at the guy like in this
area we're in now where you get you know
middle class people with dirt under
their fingernails who you know leave
their work boots outside right these
people are a thousand times the man that
these losers who are worth fortunes and
have all this power who basically
facilitated this guy's BS I mean you'd
call that out in a minute you'd be like
wait wait wait calm down with this like
what's going on here and nobody ratted
this guy out you ever you ever hear of
denmarky no governance at random
so the idea is Congress would be you
wake up one day and you go to your
mailbox and you go oh honey I got
Congress Duty you know I got to go out I
gotta go for congress it can't be any
worse
so the reason I think that'd be better
at least to some degree is if it's a
limited Congressional run where you get
Duty and you go and then there's like
they would do the same thing to do with
jury and ask you questions and stuff and
then some people like people could
approve or reject is that after you vote
for something you got to go back home
you don't get a lifelong appointments
you don't get access you don't get a
lobbying job and you're sitting there
being like yo if I vote for this Bank
bailout my neighbors are going to scream
in my face I ain't doing it I'm only so
that that's that's what I you know when
you mentioned the first hundred names in
the phone book The reason why I think
we've got so many problems is that the
people we have in government are the
people who want Power not the people who
want a good country and I was thinking
about this there's a story about these
uh six women Runners on the podium first
three are advancing to stay right fourth
place girl loses because she gets bumped
by a biological male the only so the
first place girl no complaints second
place is the biological male cheering
and happy third place female no
complaints fourth place who would have
been in third place thumbs down angry
pouting then you get fifth and sixth not
a complaint you know why none of these
people are willing to stick out their
necks for their neighbors or their
community and I think that's one of the
biggest problems plaguing our country
right now so you end up with politicians
like AOC who will just lie cheat and
steal all day and has a whole bunch of
people who aren't smart enough to know
that they're being manipulated or
cheated or like it supporting people
like her and then the people who
actually are good people like imagine if
we had like you know like Senator Dan
bongino for instance someone who clearly
cared and actually believed in something
but here's the thing I did
but that's why I lost and this is this
is the issue right five one percent or
whatever yeah sure yeah man why why
would a corrupt system want you in that
system they'd be like this guy this we
gotta we gotta fight tooth and nail to
keep this guy out and so the good people
who really do want positive changes
either don't think it's worth the fight
because it's painful and have the
talents to succeed in other places and
be effective in other ways and the only
people who are willing to go into
government are the people who are not
good at anything except they're willing
to lie cheat and steal for power if
you're really good people will support
you and you will lead with genuine
earned Authority through you know honor
but if you need to seize the title to be
someone's leader I don't think that
really implicate implies that you're
gonna have it I ran I ran three times
and you learn a lot I think it's what
pissed me off so much and how I fell
into kind of radio and podcasting
because I got so aggravated about the
system and what Tim saying is right I
mean people who have very mercenary me
for verse kind of power hungry attitudes
do very well I'll never forget being in
a Capitol Hill Club and I'm running and
it's the first time like we're my first
Senate race nobody took us seriously we
won the Primary by like some Act of God
like I ran for Senate the first time out
of the shoot we won the Republican
primer it was like the weirdest thing
against 10 people and we you know by a
sliver but the second time it was kind
of serious like people thought gosh this
guy can because we wound up raising like
a good chunk of money but I'm in the
Capitol Hill Club and I'm with this uh I
don't know some group or something like
that and it was a was a strange thing
they sent out a questionnaire before you
meet with them and long and short of it
it's about a patent thing like first of
all versus first to invent like
something so esoteric like only really
like a limited number of people care
about it and I had a very specific
stance on it because it mattered to me
like I researched and did the homework
on all the issues and I'll never forget
them like almost kind of implying like
hey you know if you say the opposite you
know and I thought you know how many
people probably just told them yes for a
cheap campaign donation because they
don't care like no one's even gonna
notice and I remember walking out I'm
not I'm trying to like virtue signal
anyone I mean I'm a sinner like but I I
like anyone else but I wasn't doing that
like because I knew once you once you
kind of once you sold a little bit of
your skin to pound the flesh was next
and I'm like I'm not doing it and I
walked out and I was like nah man like
that's my position I appreciate you
meeting with me I hope you'll reconsider
later on but I'm not doing squat I'm not
selling on anything and then when I ran
you know we were in The General
you know against this guy in this
congressional district Delaney who's
since left he ran for president left
they had this drone cat now
but uh you know I remember everyone
telling me Oh listen you need to
moderate you know you need to moderate
it's it's a it's a d plus six District
No Republicans going to win as a
conservative you know if you just like
don't mention abortion or anything like
that
and I gotta tell you man this is why I
think focus groups and politics are full
of bullshitters now because everything
they told me was fake I never changed
the damn thing we lost by one point
everyone else who ran lost by 15. so I
don't believe any of that you know I was
sitting in a group after Mitt Romney
lost to Obama down in DC this group I
was a part of uh is Groundswell Group
which was good people and it was just
like this focus group guy in there and
he said don't ever mention immigration
again we're never gonna win these guys
are so stupid Trump literally runs on
build the wall and wins Pennsylvania for
the first time ever that's why I I just
good candidates find a way to overcome
with good messaging if you can stick it
on a damn Wheaties box and explain it to
someone you can win the problem is like
Tim said you get so many mercenary jerks
they're just terrible Messengers they're
just really bad and that's why I think
the Republican party without the defense
of the media we just continue to lose I
think good people don't want to do bad
things to win like you were saying you
don't compromise your values how do you
win against someone you're playing a
game of Monopoly I'll put it this way
and the guy you're playing against keeps
pulling money out of the bank and
sticking his pocket and you're like hey
you can't do that and he's like no it's
fine how do you win against somebody
when they're just like I'm gonna keep
doing no matter what you do you're
actually playing against the people that
are drawing the board on the table and
like how do you win when someone can
just rewrite the complete structure of
the board itself like Kennedy tried John
Kennedy yeah you know he said out loud
I'm gonna change the structure of the
board guys and they're like no we're
going to rewrite the board so that
you're dead
you got an establishment
Democrats and Republicans and they work
together they do not like actual
politicians so what I end up seeing is
you get a trump and why do people like
Trump so much is because he's finally
somebody who he's talked a long time
about running and saying he wouldn't do
it remember that interview back in the
day with I think it was Oprah and he's
like you know I wouldn't run but if I
did hear the things that I would focus
on and he finally decides he is going to
run and it it feels like I think to a
lot of people it's the first time
someone who should run is actually
running despite his his crass
personality you know he's a guy who is
not supposed to be the politician the
politicians all wear the same suits
they'll talk the same way they all
Pander to the same same in the same ways
Hillary Clinton shows up in you know
whatever state with a fake southern
accent AOC shows up to a rallying as a
fake Puerto Rican Latina thing
it's fake it's fake and then you get a
trump and sure he might be rude but
people kind of feel like
we keep asking for people to run for
office who are real people who actually
care and they don't want to do it why
would you it's it's torture you're going
fighting that mission this environment
it's the system isn't built right at the
moment with all this technology that we
still have to like mail pieces of paper
across the world and hope that it lands
in a box and gets counted and that
they're just going to tell us the answer
and we have to believe they're they're
what they tell like that's 1870
technology and and why would I want to
be part of a system that is 100 disagree
with you you're totally wrong totally
wrong again I got to tell you back in
the day there were much less people and
there were physical bouts that could be
checked with tons of people standing
around staring now it's all code behind
the scenes you can't see we should be
able to see that right right so yeah but
I'm actually in it I'm actually arguing
you're on point with your own Point
we've long talked about how the problem
is proprietary private election systems
instead of publicly uh publicly
controlled open source ones so but but
the point I was getting to is not to to
open up the box of worms on do we trust
certain companies my point is simply the
quality of of candidate is very very low
the people that are leading the world
are in the private sector right now like
politicians do have some sway over the
military unfortunately or unfortunately
okay but really the people that are in
control of Earth are the people that own
Google or that Elon Musk people that are
very very wealthy they own the oil you
know they're they're you don't know
their names sometimes so I don't I think
that the real quality leaders aren't
drawn to politics they're drawn to
business because business is is more so
meritocratic so why is it that Dan
bongino and I both run these shows I
mean you tried to run for office instead
you have one of the biggest shows in the
world instead I I actually fair question
pretty good let me ask you directly like
you know how does it happen that you
wanted to get in office you wanted to
make that change instead you're doing
something different in terms of making
that change God loves him yeah I mean no
what I mean is you tried going the route
of being a Civic leader instead you
became an influential person that
happened by accident I mean I I you know
whole story of me running for office is
just crazy like I'm in my 12th year as
an agent I'm you know 13 years away from
retiring and the thing is I'm done with
the worst part of my career the
president's detail you think oh
everybody loves the presidency no no
they hate it they love going there
because it's distinguished like that's
the thing when you go to the Secret
Service we had like five thousand four
thousand agents a limited number of
people ever get there you know everybody
thinks everybody goes to the president's
detail it's actually a small number of
guys so if you get picked it's like a
big deal so I finished like I had done
lead advances I left at the top of my
game the rest of your career is pretty
much honestly you relitigating what you
did on the PPD presidential protective
division you know you live in reliving
Your Glory Days you know it's like high
school Harry telling that pass you
through in uh the fourth quarter to win
the game so I'm done I'm in the
Baltimore Field office life is good I'm
investigating cases which I love I was a
criminal investigator of the first but
you know I just love that stuff
and then uh you know I I just I saw
Obama win
and uh obviously I'm you know I'm
getting ready to transfer to his details
I'm on Bush's detail and you know it's
weird for us the Secret Service because
one night I mean literally one night
Bush walks out of the bedroom and the
next night it's Obama like nothing
changes for you it's the same post
and um I had said
I had said to my wife about Obama I when
I saw him give the speech at John
Kerry's nomination when John Kerry
remember he gave that speech and was
electric I said man this guy is going to
be big trouble
huge trouble she remembers it to this
day and I knew the country was in some
really deep I knew we were in
trouble bad and I emailed this local
Anne Arundel County
I lived in Anne Arundel County Maryland
I emailed this guy found him online his
name is Jerry Walker I said hey Jerry
I'm just a guy man I saw his speech last
night the country's going to hell I want
to get involved he mailed me back in
like 20 minutes it was like 11 o'clock
at night he said there's a local
Republican Club near you called the
elephant Club just show up and that's
that's how the whole thing started and
in just a couple months later I I looked
at my wife and I've been bothering her I
said I gotta leave I gotta leave I gotta
get out of here maybe six months later I
said I gotta go do something I got to do
something bigger than this man I can't
just watch the country go to I mean
I'm getting a paycheck you know
governments bills are always cleared for
me everyone else is getting you know
they're still dealing with the recession
and I felt like man this ain't right
like I'm I'm not I'm not like a a
citizen grifter here like I know my
job's important keeping this this cat
alive in the white house but I I gotta I
can't do this man so I said I think I
want to run for office my wife thought I
was nuts man she thought I was totally
bananas but to her credit she's always
willing to take a chance man she's like
all right you know what you want to run
we're at a cinco de mayo party in a
cul-de-sac I'm probably like 45 Tequilas
to the wind at that point who knows and
she looked at me goes you're really
going to want to do this right I said
yeah she said all right do it I resigned
I gave him two weeks notice and I left
and I jumped into U.S Senate race
everybody laughed they said look at this
idiot was this I had no I had
nothing no money I had five emails a guy
had given me for local reporters you
know we won that primary we raised 1.2
million dollars wow we won that project
they're still stickers with your name on
it out here yeah this that race was
serious that was the next one the senate
race we got annihilated it was a
three-person racer got crushed the
independent actually spent more money
than all of us he spent seven million
bucks uh he he finished third I finished
second card in one but then we ran for
re-election here and that race was
serious man a lot of people were like
dude this guy's not screwing around man
like we would show up at the Brunswick
parade the Brunswick parade we had these
yellow shirts the pictures are still on
my Instagram we'd show up with 150
people for a congressional race walking
down the street in yellow t-shirts and
everyone was like who the hell is this
guy and for people who don't know
Brunswick is not very big no it's not
big at all you look at the pictures
these thin streets you know it's Hills
all over we came down there's a picture
of a yellow Prowler this volunteer man
had a yellow Prowler and we had yellow
shirts it looks like an army invading
Brunswick I'm telling you man we and you
know what killed me in that race we
would have won that race I got a job and
a job offer it was a pretty like
significant job offer because I was
filling in on radio while I was running
which is like a major No-No because you
know it's equal Time stuff how these
candidates didn't catch on is like crazy
but we were tearing it up on radio I get
a job offer like a month out from the
election nah maybe two months whatever
about two months out and I'm like
what do I do I can't drop out and I'm
like we didn't think we were gonna win
and like I made a I made a commitment I
made promise but for like a week I
thought this thing through because it
was like life-changing for me it was
going to happen and I did the right
thing I turned it down but I swear in
that week if we just would have knocked
on a few more doors we would have won
that race man I mean it was devastating
on Election night it was devastating we
we won on Election night was there were
the votes tallied on a machine with
proprietary software code I don't know
man but that Frederick City thing I told
you about still freaks me out that all
those people voted claim they weren't
citizens I was like what was it about
Obama that freaked you out on that first
speech you heard
listen man it was kind of old school
collectivism repackaged with a bow under
the guise of like uh faux bravado
citizenry like oh look at me I'm so
pro-america I got this success story
what's your success story again
you're a community organizer you're just
to be clear right there so you but you
get how it was packaged in Liberty
oriented capitalism-based ideas like oh
my gosh I overcame what exactly I'm
sorry what did you overcome again um you
did you were a community organizer like
what exactly did you do but I saw the
guy I'm in I'll never forget where I was
I'm in the Shelbourne Hotel in Manhattan
because I'm getting ready as a counter
surveillance agent for the Republican
National Convention which was in New
York which was after that so I'm
watching him give this speech on TV and
I'm thinking of every corrupt
destructive marxist-based politician in
human history what if they had the gift
of more than anything it's the gift of
the ability to expel carbon dioxide man
and talk and convince people that this
old idea they were packaging is
new again and I heard it I heard it new
again I heard it new again I heard old
school Marxist clap trap garbage
packaged in a way that even I'm
listening going
damn that's good let's talk about this
story here from the daily signal
exclusive leaked policy exposes Fox
news's stance on woke ideology so of
course the big story I took across and
gets ousted several reports have said he
got the boot because it was part of the
Dominion settlement but uh Dan you had a
show there huge show so I don't know if
you have any insights into this but I'll
just say outright this is like a big
exclusive where apparently now people
are coming up from Fox News saying
inside the company it is woke it is very
Lefty I think the obvious thing is
you're in New York City you got New York
City laws yeah these laws are pretty
Broad and I'm gonna get into the
heaviness of these laws but I'm curious
your experience at Fox News you know you
go from politics then you're into you
know radio now your personality now
you've got a show on Fox News did you
see any of this woke stuff there yeah
man I mean it was real now here's the
thing I I didn't work in Fox and New
Year I had my own studio in Florida and
I got to tell you fox never did me wrong
like we we would fight about a lot of
stuff and you know I said I was talking
to Megan Kelly about this last week but
it wasn't anything unusual you wouldn't
see on his show I mean it wasn't like oh
don't cover that topic or did they I
said off and like they never told me
what to talk about because I just would
have talked about it anyway I mean
there's a reason but I didn't use a
prompter on a lot of my segments some of
them we did but I would that doesn't
happen at Fox like almost nobody I think
there's one host I I think I don't think
Cavuto uses a prompter but it's for
different reasons but almost nobody it
goes without a prompter matter of fact I
had Jesse on as a guest one day in New
York I sometimes rarely I would do my
show from New York like once or twice a
you know a quarter or something and
Jesse came in and I did this big like
rant and he's looking in a prompter and
it just says like Dan ad-lib and I go on
and he's like dude did that out of your
head and he's like well how'd you hit
the mark and stuff I said oh you know it
just I just that's I'm used to talk
radio like we did our thing so no one
ever told me what to say because I
wouldn't have listened to anyway but
here's the thing like Tim brings up a
point because I
it's hard I know it's easy to you know
like pile on and if anybody is a reason
to be angry with everything going on
it's me I was there
you know I'm I'm pissed about what
happened I am I would you know the
relationship there I put a lot of time
into
but he's not wrong I mean forget this
stuff for a second I'll get to that in
this I'm not trying to avoid it but I'll
give you a perfect example the vaccine
thing they did everything they can with
me to make it easy for people to not get
canned but the Mandate but they were in
New York like they had no they would
have shut the building down I lived that
they did everything they could to make
sure nobody got can like okay you're
gonna do this and you're gonna do remote
stuff all right was it what I like them
to like punch him in the face of New
York and say this is stupid we're not
doing it
yeah but with this this is different I
mean this is kind of like I read the
story looks like like they really went
overboard with this you gotta remember
you got a lot of serious conservatives
there how are they gonna feel say you're
a a female conservative host there which
they have a few you're popping in a
bathroom and a guy walks in How's that
gonna go down there if they thought this
through has Fox News considered maybe
leaving New York
they should they should I mean listen
after the Tucker thing they've got
bigger problems I mean I I don't I'm not
sure a lot a lot of people linked it but
this is a great let me can I read
something it's quick I promise I hear
people read stuff but this was someone
gave this up to Breitbart and this kind
of explains it all they said uh because
this is kind of accurate they're talking
about why me and me and Tucker weren't
resigned and some source told them this
is from a map oil piece that uh bongino
and Carlson once Source said were
considered the two most likely to say
you to management
it's right here a network Insider said
adding that bongino gave zero and
Tucker gave even less fuss
that's kind of true that's why like I'm
not I'm not I'm not furious at them
because I wasn't the easiest guy to work
with I'm not gonna mess how did it end I
you were just doing it and then they
fired you no no so the show was number
one I mean demo and overall you know
that's remember you can't get higher
number one like we we were rocking it
man we were pulling in killer numbers
even we were a 10 and a nine at both
spots and they wanted to resign for
about six months and I I don't have an
agent I do my own deals always I don't
need it I like my own stuff so I I was
the one doing all the negotiating there
was never a question they wanted to show
ever and then about I don't know about
two weeks out
but from for the at the end of the
contract was I think April 30th or
whatever I don't remember off the top of
my head but uh about two weeks out I
noticed like the tone changed completely
and I don't know what happened I I at
that point I wanted to re-up for a year
I wanted to re-up for a year and I said
let's just punt this down the road and
let's hurry up for a year and then I
don't know it just seemed like they
weren't interested but you know the
people I would do I was dealing with
there
they were genuine with me like they
never bullshitted me at all no one ever
said to me something that didn't happen
so I can't sit here and say like you
know again it's easy for me to pile on
and I have no reason I don't work there
I'm probably never going to work there
again I may never do a hit again on Fox
but I'm not going to tell anybody fairy
tales that aren't true because that's
like short run click bait stuff but in
the long run it things your credibility
not a Tucker story it's got some angles
to it you know so I don't know if
something happened last minute that post
Dominion where they were like let's just
clean house and get rid of these two I
don't know that but you know if things
did change the last two so here's the
interesting thing about this uh leaked
policy exposing Fox news's stance on
woke ideology they they they say things
that I think are kind of obvious
considering Fox is based in New York
City that uh you your gender identity is
is protected whether or not it conforms
this is New York city and state law I'm
pretty sure
and I've long talked about how the laws
in New York City opened the door for a
major major problem if anyone actually
chooses to put it to the test
so in the daily signal article they
actually link to the New York City
Commission on human rights definitions
they say gender expression is the
representation of gender as expressed
through one's name pronounced clothing
hairstyle Behavior Voice or similar
characteristics gender expression may or
may not conform to gender stereotypes
norms and expectations in a given
culture or historical period
it actually says that meaning if you put
on a safari costume from the 1800s and
call yourself the colonel with a fake
beard that is quite literally what
they're referring to historical period
you can dress up like a pirate they
wouldn't put historical period as
protected unless they expected people to
dress up like colonial era Pirates run a
conservative company out of New York
City you cannot there is no way this you
realize this was the intention of the
left hijacking Corporate America too
right yeah ncrc and the Dei that were
like yes I call it dye stuff the ESG
stuff because they want you to violate
your own core tenant principles which
does what it obviously alienates you
from the core audience it funds you by
the way my producer gee downstairs
watching the chat he says the chat's
convinced you're on drugs they're not
used to the energy
I am not on any professional narcotics
he didn't even have any of our coffee I
didn't even have anything coffee this is
my natural history here's what I want to
say about the uh the the law in New York
City though because I I think we need
some strong people at Fox news if
there's anywhere that would be willing
to test the limits of these laws it's
someone who works at Fox News who
understands this is going too far if you
work at Fox News you can put on a full
wolf fursuit tell your boss your name is
vulciferon Herald of the winter Mists
and your pronouns are Lord vulciferon
and Lord vociferons and if they don't
use it they're in violation of the law
now as I've mentioned before I've talked
to lawyers about this in New York who
said you'll be laughed out of the
courtroom why would the law say
historical period fine show up to Fox as
an on-air contributor dressed like a
pirate with an eye patch and go Yar
thanks for having me on the air Maggie
and if they have a problem with it and
tell you you can't go on and say if you
don't let me go on I will file it I will
file a complaint with the commission on
human rights in New York City for
violation of their human rights law
let's see how quickly Fox News bends
over backwards here's what I want to see
will Fox News at that point say we
cannot allow people to show up just like
Pirates or or uh I mean it says anything
caveman you could just look like yeah or
or a Roman uh in in a toga and then go
on the air if they bar you from going on
the air they're in violation of the law
now go before a judge and say your honor
this is how I express my gender as
someone who's non-binary and it says in
the law historical period is explicitly
protected no judge is going to laugh you
out there's no other interpretation of
that it all depends on the judge sure
but if the law itself says historical
period now look when I first read this
law back in 2019 I said what would
happen I call I called a bunch of human
rights lawyers in New York I said what
would happen if I went in dressed like a
wolf or something instead I was
vociferon they said they'd still fire
you kick you out and when you go to a
judge they'll say we know what the
intent of the law is and this is not it
and they will laugh you out of the
courtroom and I said if a judge has the
right to laugh at me for the way I dress
why not a man dressed like a woman and
they're like well I mean the purpose of
the law and the intent is and I was like
okay so there could be a judge who just
says no this is different this law
explicitly says historical period
that means if you go before a judge
dress like a pirate and say it says
historical period this makes me feel the
most comfortable and confident in my
gender why can't I dress up like a busty
female pirate from the 1700s with an eye
patch
and and a fake like Keira Knightley from
uh exactly absolutely or a nudist and if
and if the judge says I reject this
historical period clothing which clearly
Falls in line then the law is basically
meaningless but I'm curious because I'll
tell you this if it were me and I worked
at Fox News and this story came out I
would show up the next day dressed like
a pirate and I would get like legit
Hollywood production quality pirate
costume and I'd be like I am going on
the air dressed like a pirate talking
like this yeah welcome to the news
program and if they had a problem with
it it's a violation of the law is Fox
News at that point going they're gonna
they're gonna be presented with one of
two scenarios destroy your audience
sacrifice your audience for the local
New York City laws or relocate
I you you mentioned the New York City
laws and I think there's Merit to that
but I do think that the ESG uh
considerations from the investors and
stuff I think that has a significant uh
amount of pressure put on on them as
well so I think the combination of the
two is probably the one that's right but
that part of the story puzzled me the
most that apparently they're they are
pitching their their High HRC scores
like a net positive it's a conservative
Network that's like a that's a stain on
your network from that but there's but
there's big investors that are like
BlackRock and stuff like that though
these uh these investment firms and
stuff like that that have a significant
effect on the the direction of the
corporation because it opens
opportunities if you play by their rules
so you may it may affect your bottom
line and you may lose like Fox may lose
uh viewers because of this the woke
stuff coming out but the in like
BlackRock and stuff like that say yeah
but I promise opportunities in the
future the fox's business model though
is is not whatever but he thinks it is
they most of their money actually comes
from Carriage fees now advertising is
obviously a good chunk of it too and
they don't want to lose it but the hard
reality is even though they were losing
some money on Tucker's show due to
boycotts and other stuff Fox News was
still generating a good chunk of change
I mean they were not in any danger of
going bankrupt or anything like that
what are Carriage fees Carriage fees are
fees paid to a cable channel to be
carried on on like say Verizon these
Cable packages so because nobody will
get cable without Fox very few people
they get paid a certain amount of money
for each user so the problem Fox is
going to have that's bigger than
boycotts ad boycotts are cord cutters
because if you're getting a carriage fee
of whatever say a dollar a person and
there's 100 million people with cable
you got a hundred million in the can
before you've sold a freaking ad the
problem is the cord cutting is speeding
up that's why when I decided I was going
to do interviews after leaving Fox I've
only done two and they've both been New
Media you guys and Megan Kelly because I
am an avid supporter of new meters this
cord cutting picks up shows like this
you have to understand like this is
going to be a dumb box in the future
okay is it they call it a smartphone
it's really a dumb box it's going to be
a transmission vehicle people are going
to want to watch Tim pool Tim pool is
going to be your eight o'clock guy
whatever Temple is your whether you
watch it on this an iPad a computer or a
monitor with Smart TVs is going to be
totally irrelevant the cable box is done
we just bought a house and and the guy
comes over to we needed a cable
traditional cable because I still watch
cable news Max and fox and stuff
the guy goes cable box he goes no we
don't even have those you got to go pick
one up yourself what do you mean you're
a cable guy he was not we don't do that
he goes everybody streams now the guy
says he hasn't looked up a cable box in
days I said really we're the only ones I
felt like I was from The Flintstones so
fox makes a lot of money from that but
you're you're not wrong like there is
pressure from places like BlackRock that
can buy up a lot and you can buy up your
stock
but if your brand and your value added
right is hey we're going to be the
conservative Channel then I'm sorry but
you got to do conservative stuff I mean
their opinion part is conservative they
got to leave New York who owns it who
owns Fox I'm looking it's 39 Murdoch
it's only 39 though so who owns the
other 50 I well someone
super chatted and said what if the
historical period was pre-civil war
Southern Belle so if you work at Fox
News show up and say you identify as
your gender is non-binary Antebellum and
where old uh pre-civil War should be
thrown out of there so fast they can't
do that this is the problem look if they
want to create these laws yeah all it
takes is someone with the willingness to
be like let's see if like let's let's
we'll play game of chicken is Fox News
look Fox News is perfect for this
because the people who work at MSNBC
like what MSNBC does the people who work
at Fox clearly oppose not all of them
but a lot on the ideology
is Fox going to say we will lose our
audience and go out of business or will
we move so it's like the pressure is on
man if you work there you can make the
difference but I wonder if they made a
commitment ever since Tucker and I you
know uh departed from the network
have they made a commitment to kind of
become like a right a right of Center
Network rather than what they were
thinking that that's where the money is
because you got to remember everyone
who's tried that has failed I could go
through a list of probably four or five
online Outlets it started as explicitly
right conservative right leaning who
decided to play down you know what IJ IJ
remember IJ review was hot man when it
started they were doing these like
nugget videos and Vine like videos they
were hot they're still around but
they're profitable I don't know but they
were blowing up they were doing right
leaning stuff and then someone I don't
know who pitched them this idea of hey
let's play it down the middle the
problem with playing it down the middle
is you just piss off both sides and you
gotta understand like the politics now
are very manichaean they're just this is
it like the next fight is the end and
the next election is the end whether
that's true or not I hope it isn't
unfortunately people feel that way it's
it's not it's not the middle it's that
it's establishment
if you are someone like Jimmy Dore who's
very clearly a leftist but you are if
you're honest about the news yeah I love
Jimmy exactly I played a clip of him
it's funny on my show on my podcast
today that's hilarious Jimmy Dore will
argue socialist economic points and
you'll be like well Jimmy I think you're
clearly wrong about that and then you'll
come to the issue of Epstein or Clinton
or the banks and you'll completely agree
because he's honest Jimmy doesn't buy
into the religion either right like the
whole religion part the ideology that
goes along with it it's like Jimmy's
straight up about like the actual
material conditions which is more close
to like original Marxism with it with uh
what is it yeah materialism I forget the
the um the phrase these but he was
really focused on materialism and Jimmy
thore does that he doesn't get into the
the the what basically boils down to
like the the almost the Theology of the
left the whole the trans stuff and the
LGBT stuff and the the the basically the
the making it like a religious uh you
don't you know anything though the fox
problem is going to be too the problem
they're going to have is conservatives
right I mean I've been embedded in this
movement a long time over a decade of my
life
conservatives don't like to get toyed
with believe me I see it like
conservatives will they will call out
conservatives over nothing nothing
liberals don't have that problem do you
realize like how dumb Liberals are I'm
sorry they're freaking imbeciles you can
lie to a liberal for five years about a
PP hoax right this it's clearly
like there was no all of them Five Years
Tim five years imagine wasting so just
do a Rachel Maddow probably does 190
shows a year before her new contract now
she's only working one day a week so
figure 190. she did 190 shows a year for
almost five years
on a story that is how are you
watching this like what you just I just
wasted hundreds of hours in my life if
you pulled that as a conservative and
and it happens difficult it's a it's a
freaking cold it happened to me today I
did this interview with uh like I said
Megan Kelly on Friday and this lady she
had stuff drives me crazy on Twitter
like I'll respond to randos over nothing
because I just get pissed off and I got
a really like attitude and I just
do some like random ladies like I heard
Dan bongino and Megan Kelly calling Ron
DeSantis a backbencher I'm done with
these two and they said Trump's tweets
aren't a problem I'm like I answered her
back I'm like did you even watch the
show because I went back and watched the
clip I'm like that's not what I said
yeah I said I supported Trump and we've
got a great bench including Ron DeSantis
that's not calling him a backbencher you
freaking idiot and it's like our people
call our people out over stuff that
didn't even happen and we're so annoyed
like you're not principled and yet the
left you can stick it to them lie to
them make up innumerable stories and
they will never give up they'll tune
into Rachel Maddow tomorrow your podcast
kicks ass yep I follow the numbers like
you do if you got caught lying about a
major thing I've got this skinny on
Governor Andrew Cuomo this is coming
down this explosive story and for five
years it turns out to be it no one
watched him pool again but that's not
what we do we're I mean it makes us
better people and I'm proud to be on the
true side of the movement and I agree
with you it's more anti-establishment
than conservative or left I totally get
that I'm vibing with you on that but if
you did the stuff lefties pull on their
audience you'd be done man finish let's
let's talk about this story from axios
Trump's 2025 Vision revealed I already
really like it because if you scroll
down it says he's vowing to get rid of
marxist prosecutors yeah
yes so uh I love how this is written as
a hit piece too yeah
yes this is awesome this should be it's
the kind donation it's the best thing
I've heard ever he wants to get the wall
he wants to get the president the
authority to hire and Fire Federal
workers he wants to reward schools that
abolish tenure for teachers it's the uh
they say
he wants to uh defund the justice
department and FBI
he's the founding great of marxist
prosecutors he wants a doj to
investigate big Pharma and Hospital
networks he wants to use the U.S
military to go after drug cartels and
Street crime he wants to eliminate an
Obama era rule requiring cities and
local governments to address residential
segregation he wants Quantum Leap to
revolutionize the American Standard of
his Quantum Leap to revolutionize the
American standard of living includes
baby bonuses to create a new baby boom
and the design of 10 New Freedom cities
in the U.S
he wants he wants National concealed
carry reciprocity
I'm like actually I was saying get me on
board with Trump 2024. I love it it's
written as a hit piece too look at this
radical agenda meanwhile every
libertarian Conservative Republican is
like this is freaking awesome this is
just straight up good Trump well it's
all good Trump the idea that he would
use the military to go after Street
crime is a little is a little concerning
and all
insane because that's not what the
military is for I disagree I think
they're lying I I think what we've heard
from Trump is that the Insurrection act
should be used against riots and what
axios is doing is they're reframing it
to make it seem like he's talking about
a dude robbing a liquor store which
would be I believe a violation of Posse
Comitatus Trump was resistant to using
the military to even stop the riots I
think what he's saying now is hey if
this happens again we'll invoke the
Insurrection then I won't be too
critical since this is a news report
about what he said rather than just what
he said but the other thing that struck
me was that he wants to give the
executive Authority the right to Fire
and Fire Federal Employees which could
be like some psycho could get into
office and fire everybody and put all
his sycophants in that's actually that's
good idea I immediately and that
schedule F's everyone yeah I love that
but but also I clicked the link and it
brings you right to his stop crime
restore safety and let me just read for
you it says the uh the the once our once
great Street cities are now controlled
by gangs cartels plagued to the mentally
ill and drug addicted homeless Trump
will Revitalize police departments and
reclaim safety dignity and peace for
law-abiding Americans who deliver record
funding to higher retained police
officers strength and qualified immunity
and other protections for police
officers increase penalties for assault
on law enforcement put violent Defenders
and career criminals Behind Bars and
surge Federal prosecutors and the
National Guard into high crime
communities the only thing that remotely
comes close he's in the military for
Street crime is National Guard and high
crime communities that's something we do
we we do the National Guard is deployed
in extreme circumstances if the bulk of
what he's saying is revitalizing police
departments for axios to frame it as he
wants to address Street crime with
military is a lie yeah hopefully he's
not talking about putting like the
National Guard on the south side of
Chicago standing on the street corners
with AKA I think he's talking about when
the deploy the National Guard to
Ferguson when there was widespread
writing and that was Obama who did that
I promise they won't have ak-47. you
Evan Ferguson protesting the streets and
they deployed the National Guard when
you have certain degrees of high crime
they deploy the National Guard into
certain areas it happens a lot depending
on what that crime is yeah and usually
you got to ask for it the state's got to
ask for it uh the federal government and
it's the state level anyway it's not
something the president does so with
that being said Ian I like that you're
skeptical about that yes it is I I was
one of the few I'm still getting
about this when uh uh buchale and then
uh they did these big uh prison camps
for all these gang members I was one of
the few guys the conservatives are still
ripping me for this but that's fine
because I'm not going to change my
position I was one of these guys saying
ah you really sure about that we want to
round up like five six hundred thousand
people or whatever and throw them in
like a prison camp or all celebrating
like uh there's no more like pro cop you
know Pro let's crack down use broken
windows policing guy to me but you know
we have to be careful as conservatives
who support Liberty to not like be like
liberals like you're the current
thingers the current thing oh look
there's a guy down there in South
America who's cleaning up the streets
yeah well how did he do that like I can
clean up the streets too like I'll hire
a bunch of Special Forces guys like
whack five six hundred bad guys the
streets are clean but like have we
considered the externalities of that so
I'm with you like I'm always skeptical
when I when I hear something and that's
good I agree but my question is at what
point are you at in a war or are you
dealing with a circumstance of uh uh uh
Mark and reprisal so with the issue of
uh cartels or like an El Salvador you
have extra governmental entities that
become governments at what point are you
at War
well listen in his it's a fair it's a
fair question to ask at what point are
you at War I the problem is who gets to
declare that then
right this is because you're asking a
good question but but my question is
another question
what happens if you get an Obama then
who says uh you know what we're at a
state of war and these conservatives uh
they're talking about a stolen election
that's all treason and you're all going
to go to jail so I I would rather err on
the side of Extreme Caution and have
limits on the on the uh on the natural
vicissitudes of men's emotions than to
have this kind of Open Season attitude
and I find what people do is they get
desperate and Desperation you know
here's the thing I use this analogy on
my show a lot right you ever see The
Walking Dead before we woke I used to
loved that show then it went crazy and a
bunch of books or whatever there's that
that that season where they go into
prison but to get away from the zombies
and I say to my audience all the time
like who the walks in a prison right
locks the door in because the prison is
a bad thing the answer is people who are
afraid of what's on the outside
um that's who does that oh look the
zombies on the outside are worse than us
taking away our own freedom in a prison
that's what worries me about
conservatives specifically you know I'm
not saying like championing but what
they did El Salvador is is a horrible if
it works out great fine and civil
liberties eventually are respected but
you've got to understand like this is
the kind of stuff that tyrants love they
love to scare you enough because their
fear is the coin of the realm right that
you'll crave this too oh man can we do
that here and then you get an Obama
Biden and you're the one in the freaking
handcuffs and you're like holy did
I sign up for this and that's what
happened with the Patriot Act
so the issue that I see is if principled
people are constantly going up against
unprincipled people the unprincipled
people will win people who are willing
to like I was talking about Monopoly
right if you're planning on someone
who's actively cheating and won't stop
but you keep playing anyway my question
is I I like what El Salvador is doing I
don't know the I'm not going to say I
know every single detail on every single
thing they've done but they when I think
like three months without any murders
since it started rounding up the
criminal cartels
you've got a bunch of people who are
actively in these so so I'll let's
reframe this into the United States the
left wants to release people from jail
they're saying you know this guy was a
shoplifter let's release him what does
he do he goes right out right away and
shoplifts again gets caught and starts
laughing saying y'all caught me the
first time and let me go
it's very difficult to know how we deal
with problems like this at scale when a
country is a lot smaller there's a lot
less people we're very very libertarian
but the bigger issue at play was a
shared sense of community where most
people shared religious values and there
was a lot less people when militia meant
the local men who would take up arms to
defend their Community now you have a
place like New York City where people
don't even know who lives next door to
them and so what happens is you get a
guy on a train threatening people
everybody just puts their head down and
ignores it no one's doing anything I'll
so I'll put it this way the the solution
to this problem
in the most extreme circumstances may be
the Insurrection act sending out the
National Guard or the Army to stop Mass
unrest in the United States the real
solution is shared moral Frameworks
which we don't have and rebuilding that
takes generations and so it's been
destroyed and dismantled over the past
couple Generations
it may come to a point where you've got
a left that is saying abortion up to
nine months no questions and we've had
these people on this show say that
outright yes and I'm like that's crazy
to me and here I am traditionally in the
Democrat Camp of pro-choice meaning in
the first trimester or the first six to
ten weeks or 12 weeks or 15 weeks we'll
find that number even Trump said
something like that conservative saying
no no we're pro-life no abortion no
matter what yet I am more aligned with
conservatives in that we all recognize
taking the life of a baby that is
completely capable of serving on its own
makes no sense that's just insane so
what happens when you have a state like
Colorado where they're actively aborting
I'm doing air quotes here babies at the
point of birth because it's legally
allowed should the federal government go
in and start arresting these doctors and
Prosecuting them at what point do you
then have the left saying you are the
authoritarian fascist arresting medical
professionals and they frame it the way
they want
I think it's time for us to um
give a big double barrel you to the
left um pardon the language here folks
uh why do we give a about what the
left is saying so you're telling me that
the side recommending genital mutilation
uh saying we should put kids in
schools and inner cities for Generations
that have no chance of prosperity the
side that won't pay a freaking dime in
extra taxes themselves that demands a
sit on their fat asses and do nothing
all day while you support them through
your meritocratic work that we should
take them seriously when oh look you
guys are the fascist because there's an
infant child that does nothing that says
nothing wrong we're not going to suck
its brains out and you want to do
something to stop I don't really give a
what the left says so I I don't I'm
not suggesting you do I'm just saying
like if you want cutesy time and stuff
like I'm definitely not your guy because
I give zero this is the point
when do you send the federal law
enforcement to go arrest them on
Colorado see that's different that's
different that's a different argument
because there is an option there like if
we're talking about you can't transfer
the abortion argument over to that
because we're talking about like sucking
out a kid's brains in a post-birth
abortion or we're talking about crime
and law enforcement like we have an
option why I lived through it in New
York City so before we send in the
National Guard and talk about any
military intervention we could just do
like what we actually did in New York it
was called broken windows policing
wasn't even complicated they just went
out I mean we don't have time to go over
the whole thing here but the essence of
it is really really simple they went out
and said hey we should just arrest
people for doing like crimes like it
can't be that simple no I promise you it
was when I got out of the police
department the whole idea was listen we
need cops on the corner so if you you
see a kid jumping a turnstile in a train
station let him go Tim because you know
what I need you out there I can't have
you processing this kid all night that's
not a dumb idea you're like yeah that
makes sense we want to prevent the
robberies in a rape's not that well what
happened the dude who jumped the
turnstiles the guy who rapes the woman
he hasn't paid a fare but so you catch
him there and they cleaned up New York
overnight this is my point
when Trump gets elected do we send in 2
000 agents to start arresting all of the
doctors all of them they all have to be
arrested because they're all
facilitating abortion to the point of
birth if you are killing an infant child
in violation of the law then I'm really
sorry but you made that decision so in
El Salvador when you've got 10 15
000 guys in one area who are all
obviously displaying tattoos working as
guards actively participating in in
seditious actions yeah then they send in
the government they arrest them all and
the problem is when we get these photos
of all these gang members being arrested
and you get people of good principles
saying like I'm kind of worried about a
government going and rounding all these
people up
now people in El Salvador I met a guy in
DC from El Salvador and uh some he was
talking to another guy I heard him
mention something but I said are you
from El Salvador says yes and I said
what do you think about what's going on
and he says I left there a long time ago
but now it's getting really really good
and I'm gonna go back I'm like someone
who moved to America is now wants to go
back to El Salvador so my concern is
this I completely agree we have to be
worried about a government that goes
Rogue like we like it was conservatives
who were very gung-ho on Patriot Act
stuff and uh Bobby man not necessarily
yeah you go back and look at my campaign
videos and it was Obama who signed the
indefinite detention provision so I'm
not saying it's just Republicans but uh
you know Luke brings up how he was
trying to tell Republicans like hey man
watch out for this this DHS stuff is
going to come and bite you in the ass
it's hard to know whether what you're
doing will work out perfectly but I I
think it's a losing position to be like
hey I don't want to go and arrest a
thousand people because of the the the
um what the president set if another bad
person gets in office it's like not you
gotta arrest bad people doing bad things
even if it means it looks bad so you end
up with people in law enforcement saying
I'll give I'll give you a story actually
I was just skating in uh Hagerstown
skate park and the local guys over
Hagerstown Maryland you know where he's
at I know it well yeah they said a gang
of young kids came there I believe this
was not this past weekend but uh oh
actually no this was uh this was Friday
I think and beat the crap out of a guy
and robbed him and the cop said we won't
do anything we can't do anything about
it we can't lay a hand on these kids and
if anyone else does they're getting
arrested because they're concerned about
what the locals will the public will
think about cops coming in and grabbing
a bunch of kids and roughing them up and
arresting them in the scene that it
causes so they're like we're gonna back
away from it and this leads to out to
excessive lawlessness the solution would
then be having a team of cops come out
in gear grabbing 12 kids pinning them
down and arresting them all and then you
get a ton of videos of cops in in
specialized armor fighting a mob of kids
a gang
you gotta arrest them you gotta arrest
them if if but I'm not saying not arrest
him I'm just saying like what I'm saying
is the state is Corpus bring forth the
body and show me some evidence but
that's the thing but they're not going
in El Salvador just being like no
charges of trial you're being
renditioned no I I I listen I'm not
suggesting that every single person in
that jail or even even a a even a small
minority most of them probably you know
it
I was let me tell you the story can I
tell you a quick story oh yes I'm
working out I'm working a big kid we're
doing a profit I'm a federal agent I'm
not a cop anymore I'm working with the
Secret Service I'm in a proper session
with this guy properly called a King for
a Day deal bad guy's lawyer comes in
you're sitting around a table no
different than this basically whatever
he says in there they call it King for a
Day because we're not going to use it
against them unless he lies if he lies
then he can use it so it's called the
proper session we're in there with this
guy we get this guy this is a massive
massive like fraud scheme going on I'm
gonna say the guy's name obviously but
we pull out a photocopy of his driver's
license
we slide it across the table
it's the wrong guy it's not the guy
it's a different guy I'm like he turns
around he goes that's not me we're like
it wasn't my case it was partly was it
I'm like holy that's not this guy
now the crazy thing is the guide
admitted to like 20 or 30 different
crimes proper session which is so and
we're like what the hell do we do now
this guy because it's a proper it's a
king for a day my point is that like we
have rules and procedures and those
rules and procedures have to matter
there were as much as I would have loved
to have pulled that guy at her in
handcuffs ah the rules you just
admitted to all this stuff we're gonna
we know you did it the hard reality is
once those rules go away and it becomes
a discretion of people in power they
will always always abuse it always but I
don't think that's what so so this
conversation starts with El Salvador
specifically I don't I don't think
that's what El Salvador is doing I think
now what you're actually seeing is a
president who said we're going to uphold
the law as the law is meant to be upheld
instead of governments that were working
with the criminals yeah but you got to
worry about the guy that comes after
bakely that's the problem I I just don't
I just don't see this making sense a
president comes in El Salvador and says
hey all these things are doing is
illegal and these cartels were working
with governor officials now that I'm
here I'm gonna start arresting him for
crimes I'm not I'm I am I am not worried
about what happens next because the next
president should uphold the law in the
exact same way but the thing is they're
they he's arresting them for crimes it's
not right we're not crime that's why I'm
saying
I'm not suggesting like El Salvador oh
they can just get a fine little court
system like we had in New York and the
NYPD like they obviously don't have the
judicial structures we do or the
Fidelity to process like we do so I
don't make the enemy there that's why I
don't like I'm not condemning the guy
like oh he's full of you know what
there are going to be a lot of people
who live because of that my point I
guess in this whole thing and where I
want to get I don't want to be confused
with you or get sideways on this one
is I just think we got to be very
careful championing this stuff here like
this is some kind of model for the
United States a lot of people even on
our side we're like oh my gosh if we
could only do this here like what like
spy on people without warrants like we
did for Trump like but is that what he's
doing
well how's he getting all this
information you're telling me they filed
like a hundred thousand more and I mean
they don't they're police for I do the
simple Logistics right I mean the FBI's
got a surveillance Squad they can
monitor in a city probably less than I
don't know five six hundred people far
less than at any given day you're
telling me like all of these people got
some kind of judicial process I don't
know I'm I'm afraid to Champion that I
think everyone else should be too and
you know what if it makes me like oh
what are you some kind of someone said
to me you're a bleeding hard liberal or
something I said are you a Madman like
are you crazy I'm the guy on Fox and all
these things defending the cops when
they do good police work I'm the guy
doing that so I'll give you an example
in DC on January 20th 2017 or 21st I
think it was
several hundred far left extremists were
firebombing Vehicles setting fires in
the streets smashing Windows they all
wore black intentionally they told a
bunch of people they told everybody hey
show up on this day we're going to
protest Trump wear all black
when they are when the cops surrounded
everybody and arrested arrested several
hundred of them
the court said
we can't prosecute you because we are
required to prove as an individual you
committed the crime
so the Government tried charging them
with conspiracy because they all chose
to wear black to hide the crimes of the
individuals in the crowd and the court
said you can't do that
prove to me that man right there through
the fire bomb or he is free to go
so the only people who got criminally
charged were those who pled pleaded
guilty and that was early on until the
ngos came in and said no no don't worry
to all the leftists if you committed
felonies we will make sure you never see
a minute in jail not only were these
people freed after destroying DC in an
Insurrection they sued the city and won
large sums of money a society that
functions that operates that way can't
function when you have the inverse
happening to the other side so you have
the far left extremists firebombing
buildings smashing windows and the
courts say sorry then you have January 6
and they say we will hunt you down to
the ends of the Earth and lock you up
indefinitely without charge or trial
that's where we're currently at so if my
point is this if you're staring at an
opponent who is cheating to the extreme
degree and you keep saying no no we're
going to let them keep doing it we want
them to stop maybe one day we can stop
them I'm just like at a certain point
the question is for El Salvador the game
things are working with the government
and they all know who the gangs are they
know who the bosses are and it's corrupt
as a corrupt can be so there's death
nobody wants to be there
you get someone comes and says we know
these guys are they got the tattoos
we've got the records because they were
colluding with government let's start
arresting them I'm not saying it's
perfect I'm not saying I know everything
that happened I'm just saying right now
we're dealing with in the U.S is I watch
the far left burn down cities and the
courts then say well we agree with Dan
bongino on this then when the right goes
in protests in Portland the cops say
nope we're going to lock them up because
you know they're part of a group yeah
but the irony is like you're in all
black
you could have been caught up in that
sent to jail illegally right I wasn't
wearing all black right now and I was
arrested but the people wearing all
black what if you had no recourse they
were all wearing they were wearing
hoodies and masks and so you had a group
of two 300 people all dressed
identically for the explicit purpose no
I get it but you see my point like what
if you were just an innocent you're
wearing black right now what if you guys
I was wearing all black and I was
arrested yeah and I had a press card I
messed up and the cops pulled me out and
said you can go home now yeah but what
if you couldn't because you had all
black on that's my point like if you
show up to an antifa rally dress like
antifa and you stand in a crowd of
antifa throwing firebombs at people well
that's different that's what they're
doing no but you didn't do that no and
that's why I got let go I wonder where
we disagree like the the point that we
don't have an actual justice system
right now one that we do have a justice
system that's blind it's blind to the
Democrats a political party there's no
error between us they're like I
absolutely agree my simple suggestion
here is that there's a there's a way to
fix that and the way to fix that and the
only way to fix it it's not violence
because once you cross the red line it's
over like there's no going back going oh
I'm sorry I killed that guy like once
you go down that path there's just no
and I think a lot of people who talk a
lot of about violence have never
been there like if you guys actually sat
there at a crime scene with like a
dude's head blown off on the potatoes in
a freaking Bodega we're near the new you
know what that looks like it doesn't
even look real like it looks fake it
doesn't look real if you've never seen
it I swear like you're like wow that
guy's head split in half like that's
kind of crazy like I can see the
cerebellum like that so we have a way to
fix this stuff we have a constitutional
process the fact that it's broken isn't
like ah it let's just like throw it
out and declare like martial law but no
saying that I'm saying Trump should when
Trump gets in he should file every
criminal indictment yes if he if he's
fire everybody I just said that I I
don't know I I think fire those who
deserve to be fired but if you smell
even the lightest scent yes of anything
criminal yes but we totally agree I to
the camera I concur with Tim Paul we I
don't know why
I mean you guys are just outlining a an
inherent problem with liberalism which
is you liberalism takes the opposing
view seriously and it's charitable like
in essence the whole point of that's
where we get our our innocent until
proven guilty uh idea is because we look
at the person and say there we assume
they're good we assume that they're
going to be innocent we assume they're
virtuous and that's the way we approach
let me let me let me put it this way
when the left gets when uh I see a
leftist get censored on Twitter I will
not defend them you said you don't
believe in free speech okay I'll give
you I'll grant you your wish to the
people who don't believe in
constitutional rights don't stand for
then actively oppose it I will not
defend them
there's this meme of the left shares
from Carl popper about tolerating
intolerance and they say we can't
tolerate hate speech because the
intolerant eventually take over and kick
out the tolerant and I'm like
okay
if you want to come to me and tell me my
Constitution and things I believe in
should be destroyed then when it comes
to how out our community which is a
sphere of influence that says here are
the rights that are granted to you if
you actively oppose those rights I will
make sure that when it comes when you
are guilty of a crime you don't get them
because you don't want them well you
don't have to defend them and you
probably shouldn't but defend the rights
themselves agreed so if someone is
falsely accused and we don't have
evidence we defend them but if someone
is a known antifa guy who is caught
red-handed and on camera saying F the
Constitution F this country Fu Colonial
whatevers and starts throwing fire
although those lawyers in New York I say
I don't I don't I don't I don't care to
defend them if they don't like look my
point is this at a certain point you're
in a culture war and there are people
actively trying to destroy your culture
and your values if we keep protecting
them and they're exploiting our system
to destroy us we will lose I was
fighting about this with people or not
you're not fighting about this this is a
point that I've been trying to make on
Twitter it's so entertaining to watch by
the way which is
America is a liberal country and the
people that are actively trying to
corrupt our government are not liberals
they are authoritarians and you have to
understand that authoritarians have a
completely different Philosophy from
liberals liberals believe that honesty
is a virtue right authoritarians don't
believe that you get consequentialists
who believe that the actual results are
the the important part so someone like
vosh V right he'll say things like and
this is paraphrasing but he says things
like I want to win for socialism I don't
want to lose for socialism so that means
it's okay for me to lie that when he
came here and he was on with Charlie
cook he was pleasant Etc and then he
goes back to his show and he's just the
most vile scumbag he did it he does it
to leftists and stuff and the point is
you can't believe people just because
they say you know just because of what
they say you have to understand where
their philosophy comes from and if
you're if you're not a liberal there's
no reason to believe that the person
that's coming to you respects liberal
principles and there's no reason to
believe that they're going to be honest
that's that's it I'm not a Libertarian
in the Big L sense I lean on the
libertarian spectrum and I'd probably be
more towards traditional or classical
liberal I probably have a view that
looks at the world not too dissimilarly
to Starship Troopers service guarantee
citizenship kind of concept
my fear is this why is it that no
Anarchist civilization has ever
prospered
it's because points property rights well
anarchists uh depending on your
definition don't necessarily disagree
with that the issue is that they don't
move fast enough and in times of an
emergency you do need Executive
Authority and therein lies the big
challenge you I I don't believe you can
simply just say we will always uphold
every guaranteed right no matter what
there are certain lines we obviously
don't cross like we're not going to
rendition people you know that's that's
across the line but they're they're
making a point where a country is at War
a country at War can't be like well our
our the West Coast was just invaded a
whole bunch of Chinese boats landed
they're currently taking over our cities
in order to do this right-wing to
convene Congress to just determine
exactly what we're going to do and how
we're going to do it and then uh you
know the session will resume tomorrow
meanwhile cities are blowing up people
being killed the reason why we have an
executive branch is so that the
president can make emergency decisions
in terms of the military so if we did
get invaded on the West Coast or Alaska
the president does not need to go to
Congress he can be like we have to act
now we are being killed boom pulls the
trigger the challenge is when do we
determine that we are in active conflict
with people who seek to destroy us if if
foreign Nationals invaded the US and
started committing acts of Terror
we would give them certain rights like
International War rights and things like
that but for the most part you're at War
crazy stuff happens and the rules of War
only matter when it's controlled in
limited Warfare like I think Henry
Kissinger talks about right yeah limited
Wars his ideas real war means nothing
like I hear these things like war crimes
were committed I'm like yo that doesn't
matter if there's a regime that commits
every war crime in the book and then
wins the book will never mention a war
crime being committed and the idea of
war crimes won't exist because the
person who wins the war wins so my point
is simply this people are people are
pointing out in the Super Chat that he
suspended the Constitution FairPoint I
agree not a good thing but if we're if
we're if we're facing an existential
threat where a group of people are
seeking to burn the Constitution to the
ground do we say let's protect those who
are like you've got people outside of
federal building in Portland trying to
burn it down and we kept going well you
know but they have rights so 90 days of
fire bombs being allowed at a federal
building and nothing being done that was
just negligence I mean it was obvious
crimes people I mean Kyle servant was on
your show was there like they saw crimes
and it was just shitty police work I
mean let's just be honest but we already
kind of have we haven't established a
Judicial principle about when we're
allowed to violate rights especially
when it applies to things like religion
a compelling government interest
two-pronged test right and the least
restrictive means that's a pretty good
guidepost for a violation of any Reds
because you're going to have to violate
people's rights right you have the right
to assembly right but if the assembly
tomorrow was a a call for the open
overthrow via violent means of the
United States and the assassination of
the president that's going to be broken
up because there's crimes being
committed right like if you have a
religion for example and the religion
says whatever it's Joey Vega donutsism
and it says we're going to bloodlet on
children until we take six pints of
blood the chat is loving Joey Vega
Donuts it's the most New York thing that
you've been dropping I'm enjoying the
hell out of it too personally only guy I
know but if it said we're gonna bloodlet
children for six weeks straight take a
pint of blood every day you have freedom
but you can't because there's a
compelling government interest we don't
want the kid to die and the least
restrictive means would would be to come
in and say not lock people up and say
hey is there a different way for you to
celebrate that like I don't know maybe
an animal sacrifice or something right
so we already have established
guideposts but I I take your point that
we one of the things I think we
specifically in the United States
especially liberals which drives me
crazy tend to do and you know them well
like you know more liberals than I do
um is they tend to transplant our values
overseas with this like spreading
democracy crap that's why I'm not I'm
like oh because like I'm not saying any
of that I'm simply suggesting with this
entire thing we have to understand that
people around the world are we are a
very Advanced culture and no American
exceptionalism is not the same as Greek
exceptions I'm like Obama said it is
literal exceptionism we are different
but that means everyone else is
different than us we are at the top of
this totem pole and transplanting that
to other countries and going oh if they
just did it better here broken windows
in El Salvador be I get it that's naive
I'm just saying like we're more we are
we are a very Advanced culture and we're
ridiculously Rich we have an established
set of principles we should follow and
because liberals don't I agree with your
proposition there we should never defend
idiots personally if you say hey I agree
with you 100 hey free speech sucks band
conservatives I'm not going to defend
you personally but I will absolutely
defend a liberal's right in general Big
R God give a right to speak so here's I
I used to be much more just like
libertarian Constitution and I still am
for the most part I used to say free
speech for everybody when a leftist got
banned I'd be like nope they have to
have their free speech protected and
then something changed so let me let me
ask you
um do you think parents have the
ultimate say in what their kids uh uh uh
learn or uh uh we'll start there do you
think parents have the ultimate say in
in terms of what their children learn
yeah but what's the limiting principle I
mean are we talking about teaching a kid
again to assassinate the president
United States but the answer is no then
yeah well you're you're talking in
absolutes nothing is like everything's
on the margin there's nothing in life is
absolute I mean I wouldn't answer any
question that way do you think that's
like saying it's killing wrong well it
depends on the circumstance do you think
parents have the absolute say in the
Medical Treatments that their children
receive no I don't believe in any no
what if this says I I want what if a
parent says I want to cut off the the
the nuts of my five-year-old because
they accidentally touched the Barbie
doll so wait wait so you're saying you
know like wait so do you think the
government should be allowed in certain
circumstances to intervene to stop
parents who are giving uh or neglecting
the actual health of their children
isn't that everything no what about what
about the vaccine then the vaccine what
about what if a parent says I'm not
going to give my kids get my kids
vaccinated should the government then
come in and finish again what's the
compelling government interest there is
that child not having the vaccine gonna
hurt someone else no it's going to hurt
the child so there's no compelling
government interest it's personal but
wait hold on and second what's the least
restrictive means the least restrictive
means is just to leave it alone not to
knock some kind of new the argument is
for uh mumps for instance mumps has
started re-emerging because parents are
refusing to get their kids vaccinated
yeah but that's why they create the
mumps vaccine mandate yeah but you have
an option against that like you could go
get a mumps vaccine and you're not at
risk that was my beef with the covet
vaccine is the whole point is they
painted it out like it was a compelling
government interest because it was it
would stop Community spread and then we
found that didn't do that and then we
found out second that it didn't even
stop you from getting covered either so
yeah you know I don't like questions and
absolutes because there are no absolutes
and it's like saying heat or no heat in
Winter that's not a real question it's
like how much and this you know this is
this is my point when the uh uh the
vaccinated stuff happened you had the
left arguing the government has a right
to intervene if parents aren't doing
right by their children in terms of
medical care there's a lot of questions
about like parents make their kids vegan
and then when it came to the issue of
trans kids the right said the government
parents have no right to put their kid
through this and the government should
stop them and many people have even said
the parents should be arrested if they
try and get their kid you know uh child
sex changes and things like that so
there is no principle of parents have
rights sometimes they do sometimes they
don't and if we don't have a a if there
is no law that like principle of a
parent has the final say they don't they
don't have a final say we just have a a
morality the left argues the government
should not be able to intervene to stop
a child's sex change but the government
should intervene to give a kid a vaccine
the right says no the government should
not be able to force vaccines and
parents should not be allowed to give
their kids sex changes it's an inversion
so the real issue is just the shared
moral framework there are like you find
that even leftists like Jimmy Dore would
probably agree with the right position
on not giving kids sex changes and
there's a big distinction then between
what the left and the right is simply on
moral Frameworks not on premise but
those aren't morally equivalent you know
again apply a simple test you're talking
about a vaccine in one case at granted
may have some serious side effects okay
but as far as we know as not but killed
every single person who got it right but
then you wait but then you're talking on
the other hand about permanently
altering a young child with no capacity
for advanced decision making by cutting
their nuts off like that's not the same
thing that's why I'm saying it doesn't
need to be from my point my point is
simply that your morals are different
from the left yeah because we have them
like they don't have morals your point
is accurate the left the when you when
see the left the thing about the left is
the way people attack the left which is
completely wrong and I say on my show
all the time never do this is they
attack them on the hypocrisy front I do
it as a humor olinsky thing just to
embarrass them you're you're shaking
here because they don't care the left
doesn't care about a hypocrisy they care
about hierarchy and power see we have
morals we have a set of guiding Big R
god-given rights principles that we I
always say to people like we have an
emergency break on our behavior that
left this Stone have right I cannot
physically attack you as a principled
conservative and beat the crap out of
you because I don't like you like antifa
does to us because our rights come from
God but so do yours even if your
politics are freaking stupid the left
doesn't have that that's why they freak
me out this is my point
if you identify those who share your
moral values
if everybody in this country shared the
same moral framework you'd need very
little police officers you you'd you'd
need very little in way of life if men
were Angels
so the issue is now with the culture war
is the left has no moral framework their
moral framework is there is no truth but
power so they will say Amen brother and
the culture War right has Christian
Christian moral framework whether or not
people like Bill Maher want to
understand it or accept it the reality
is the Constitution is rooted very very
much so in Christian a Christian moral
framework that is not to me that is not
me saying everybody of good moral
standing is Christian or needs to be I'm
saying a lot of these ideas I've talked
about it quite a bit like blackstone's
formulation if it uh he says it's better
that 10 guilty persons Escape than one
innocent person suffer my point is
simply that there is no simple blaken a
blanket principle there is only the
extent to which we share morals and we
find it morally reprehensible for the
reasons you described to give a child a
sex change at the same time we find it
morally reprehensible for a government
to mandate a medical procedure the left
just wants power they will exploit our
principles and argue hey I thought you
were for parental rights you you said in
Florida parental rights and the prayer
to final say well Jazz Jennings parents
say that jazz should get a sex change
they'll they'll try to exploit you on
the fact that you have asserted this is
your principle and then they'll try to
navigate through it my response is
simply this I don't care about that I
have a moral line you cross it I tell
you to screw off that means it's not
about parents it's not about principles
not about rights free speech in my
opinion extends to those who believe in
free speech I will protect it for
everybody who says I have a right to say
it the moment some leftist comes out and
says no one has free speech rights but
me I say I look forward to you getting
arrested when you lose your free speech
rights and I won't defend you that's my
point that's my point yeah
let's go to super chats that was some
deep stuff bro I didn't even got an
ibuprofen
my thing is simply like at what point do
we do we say like hey if we keep
if we're playing a game of Monopoly like
I said before and they're cheating and
we just keep saying all right you know
we're not going to win we have to at
some point be like look you're cheating
I'm not gonna play this game with you
anymore you don't get to play with me
and my friends because you cheat all the
time so and they're like hey that's not
fair everyone's allowed to play the game
not you anymore dude because you're a
cheater the thing that sucks is is the
reaction to like the left wants the
reaction like they they always complain
about reactionaries but they start the
dialectic they initiate what is going to
make the right react then when they get
the reaction from the right they can go
ahead and say look we need to change
this or change that because look at the
reactionaries and blah blah
the way that historically a lot of
countries and this is not something that
I'm endorsing the US doing the way that
historically a lot of countries have
dealt with uh with Communists or
leftists being what the what they are
dishonest and and having a different set
of principles is it ends up being like
fascism like it ends up being like
Pinochet you know and that's not good
but it's better than Communists well
that's what I think about it we gotta go
to super chats I want to tap this out
man this Colorado nine-month abortion
thing like if it's federally legal like
the feds are not involved and it's a
state rights thing I don't think you
would want to send the feds over there
to bust it up completely disagree uh
that's the fascism route I don't know
it's not it was not fascism for the
union to be like no no slavery you know
what I mean like Hey we're not gonna
allow that humans and it wasn't it
wasn't I I know it's overly simplistic
to say because that's not what the Civil
War was the Civil War was was a wide
range of issues part of why slavery the
Emancipation Proclamation was only after
the Civil War already started my point
is if there are people in a state that
it's like if Colorado legalizes
I mean I mean we'll just talk about
nine-month abortion like we are talking
about something so morally shocking
reprehensible the overwhelming majority
of Americans oppose it and the only way
the left gets these things through is by
lying to people and tricking them it's
why you'll often have these
conversations with leftists and I'll
give you a really really simple one it
really confuses me why is it that
leftists are so afraid to say that they
are homosexual
they're they they so so and it may seem
like a silly example but I I I genuinely
mean it Lance from the serfs comes on
the show and says that it is
heterosexual straight for a male to
engage in adult activities with another
male so long as that male is effeminate
and I think he's messing with us dude
they're not they've made this argument
for like 10 years you got to pay
attention to stuff I remember seven
years ago you said that if you trans
lesbians exist and you are completely
you're completely wrong on the scenes
man anyway so my point is why are they
so afraid to admit that they're gay
because I got no problem with people at
work at all but this guy Lance comes on
the show and says he thinks it is
straight for for a male to to engage in
activities with the male so long as the
males are feminine he even said to you
Ian that if a male was to engage in
relations with a manly ugly woman that
would be gay
they've made this argument for a long
time trans lesbians have their own flag
I remember this 10 years ago they were
talking about if you are a female who
won't date if you are a lesbian who
won't date a trans woman you are
transphobic right and so my point is
simply this if you're a male and you
like males that's called homosexual
because you both have the same you know
makeup essentially wedding tackle but
for some reason they for some reason
they refuse to say they're like
embarrassed they refuse they reject it
they're not playing Fair they're lying
they won't admit what they actually
think and they will lie to you to get
what they want I think the reason
they're afraid to say it is because they
know that if they go to a regular
average person and say you're gay then
they're going to be like hey screw you
no I'm not so they lie and say no no
you're totally straight if you if you
suck on that dude you know what I mean
or that that trans woman sorry it's a
lie to manipulate people the only way
they get away with it so my point going
back to abortion Colorado outright says
there are no restrictions at any point
in abortion if you go to the average
American say
should a baby at the point of birth
should a doctor be allowed to kill that
baby one person out of 100 might say yes
a leftist maybe however many leftists
there are but what if you say
if the mother deems an abortion
necessary should there be any
restrictions on that they're gonna say
no no no because in their mind they're
thinking two weeks pregnant a panicked
mother who's impoverished or suffering
some medical problem they're not
thinking about what the left is actually
trying to do nine months so my point is
if they're doing that at the
governmental level I believe that
violates the 14th Amendment I believe
that if a baby can survive on its own
it's protected by the Constitution and
the federal government should go in and
arrest every single doctor but and I'm
not even staunchly pro-life I'm just
saying if the baby can live nobody has
constitutional rights no baby can
survive on its own they need constant
medical no human can survive on its own
I know then you are still still adult
humans can live alone no they can't you
could get a homestead out there and most
humans humans being social creatures for
the most part struggle to survive I mean
little babies will die within 24 hours
or 48 Hours the duration to which a
human Will Survive by themselves is no
merit and whether or not they get
constitutional rights oh well that's not
what I'm saying should an adult with no
arms and legs have no constitutional
rights no then why wouldn't the baby I'm
not saying that the baby shouldn't have
constitutional rights okay then a baby
has a 14th Amendment right not to be
killed
um if it's the mother that's having an
abortion with a it's not a human uh at
that legally then I'm just talking about
the law and that you got to leave it up
to this I think you got to leave it up
to local law enforcement like this
broken policing broken windows policing
policy wasn't the feds going in there
and breaking up New York it was low you
leave it to the people if they really
think it's abhorrent though police every
step of the way throughout history
they've argued that the people that they
enslave torture and murder aren't real
people so I do not accept it
a baby that can survive I I don't like
abortion and I'm pro-choice simply
because there are very very difficult
libertarian questions on when the
government is allowed to intervene what
knowledge the government is allowed to
have and within a certain time period
the mother and the doctor having to make
difficult decisions and I also agree
that abortion is exploited as
contraception which I think is
disgusting
however at a certain point if the baby
can survive on its own then I think
killing it violates inalienable rights
constitutional rights and my my stance
then would be if if you have like this
is what I was talking to Lance about if
the baby has to come out of the mother
anyway why kill it if it can survive on
its own that was great I don't know if
you know I played that on my podcast
it's interesting because we're talking
about you know you're correct in your
assertion that the world is not black
and white the whole pool of Ethics is
about gray areas ethics is entire
courses taught in college because really
what in life is black and white I mean
there's so few things right like I said
oh don't kill oh yeah definitely don't
kill yeah but what if he comes in your
house late at night tries to like kidnap
oh okay like nothing just yeah but
ironically you brought up abortion
that's the one area for me that's just
absolutely black and white I get it
other people have different positions
I'm not indicting anyone here I'm just
saying like my record of success on this
is 100 right
every single human being on planet Earth
ever has gone through conception that
doesn't mean every conceived uh a person
has been born some there's miscarriages
you know children die in the womb all
the time there's ectopic pregnancies
things don't work out for pregnancy but
my record of success is 100 there's not
a single person's room that hasn't been
conceived so right I mean does anybody
dispute that so I'm I'm 100 for a
hundred you're zero for nothing but
people go oh I don't know when life
begins yeah I do conception oh my God
100 success so just say now I would be
more comfortable with leftists and I get
it there's different positions I would
be more comfortable with you if you
would just be honest and say if life
human life is inconvenient for me the
mom or the dad I feel I should be able
to exterminate it so I'll debate you on
it but at least you're honest they're
just full of oh no no it's not a
life it's like a clump itself
it's that person until it gains
personhood legally but I'm not talking
about legally we're talking about black
and white morals you're wiping out and
Exterminating a human life so is anybody
uncomfortable with that like think about
that they're not they're not
that's kind of like you know I I we used
to have this thing in my um my high
school I went to a Catholic High School
double quotes two quotes that were
related you have to think of something
clever so one kid came in with a gray
one uh Camu God is dead and he wrote uh
kamu is dead God uh you know like you
you don't you if you I I get it like I I
believe in my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ I'm a religious guy I'm not your
preacher I'm not your Rabbi I'm not your
Imam you do you whatever man I'm just
saying like
I'm not taking that chance man you
really want to go up there one day in
front of the Pearly Gates and be like
yeah I wiped out six kids I had six
abortions and I'm an abortion doctor and
I wiped out 2 000 lives I'm not sure
you're getting into that movie I'm
pretty sure you're kind of
factory farming too so we do got to go
to Super Chat farming man but I I do
want to say some people are like shocked
like Tim said Life begins a conception I
have always yeah but it's the difference
between life and personhood are two
different things oh well it matters no
well no I don't listen
a lot of things matter legally I mean
that that's that's a that's a that's a
non-sequitural like of course it matters
legally we have laws that try to
establish some bed mark Bedrock of
morality in a set of judicial principles
and legal principles like I totally get
that but I think the point of human life
is absolutely black or white you can't
say like well we don't know when life
begins or when it's a person so don't
wipe the kid out and guess like what
kind of answer is that so I I have a
conversation with Glenn Beck that ends
with a handshake as my I'm like oh these
are interesting questions and my
position has always been can the
government mandate one person provide
their body to another when are where are
those limits and and and restrictions
put in place how does the government
informed there's a lot of serious
challenges there if a woman so so the
problem is if a woman is forcefully
impregnated and says I never wanted this
I don't want it and you can't force me
to share my body with another life form
I don't think the government can
intervene and be like nope we are
forcing you to provide your blood and
body to this person that you never chose
and you were responsible in every
respect the challenge then is what do
they do they exploit the law for
contraception which is disgusting and I
don't have a solution there yeah but Tim
do you ever notice like when you talk
about crisis pregnancies right
grab a liberal any liberal and go okay
tell you what I'll make a deal with you
we'll pass a law tomorrow and support it
every single rape or case of incest that
there will be you can abort the child
whenever you want in in exchange for
saving every other life would you
support it no I would so you don't give
a you're just making that up you're
like I'm making you a point I get it I'm
not trying to be bad for cereal I may
I'm just kind of doubling down on your
point but because it's a crisis
pregnancy right which it is and I've we
should never ever diminish that and no
I'm a guy I don't know what it's like
obviously to Bear children there are two
genders Liberals are idiots right I'll
never understand that and I don't
pretend to that doesn't absolve us of
the responsibility of answering really
difficult questions like yes this woman
is carrying a pregnancy she does not
want that was imposed upon her in a
brutal act but that does not that does
not absolve us of the fact that we are
then killing a child and someone asked
me this once this changed my mind on
this completely I was at this uh this
this convention there and someone came
up to me it was a big pro-life Advocate
but a very nice guy very super nice guy
and he said
well why not just kill the toddler I
mean it's a child of rape and you're
like oh well why would we do that that
it's alive it's a it's alive in the womb
too and this is so this is the question
that I asked these leftists I said two
women can see that the exact same time
identically they're twin sisters who had
twin brothers who both can they both
conception after the exact same moment
at eight and a half months one woman is
going into early labor because uh you
know rough car ride something shocked
and then you know she some trauma and
boom baby's coming other sister totally
finds him in the hospital bad baby's not
coming I said at eight and a half months
the baby comes out and is delivered
perfectly healthy The Identical baby in
every single way still in the womb can
it be aborted and you have the left says
every time yes and I say What's the
difference between the layer of skin in
front of it I I but we got to go to
superchargers we are way too late I got
to do it we're gonna read these
22 says I love you guys Tim did you see
the Ukraine war has spilled into Russia
the belgarad region bordering Ukraine
looks exactly like Western built
Insurgency have you guys heard about
this at all yeah there's there's uh
there's people talking about uh uh a
separatist movement
um I haven't read a lot about it I've
seen a couple tweets uh I was going to
dig in when we got done but it's
possible they they do dig into this in
your post stuff so don't miss it right
there you go there's a plug there that
was like the first time in it so uh
we're not doing an after show we
recorded a pre-show which will be up at
about 10 p.m as soon as we wrap the show
we're putting it live because Dan's got
a hard stop he's got a bounce but uh we
appreciate you sticking around we're
coming in early so we could do the the
pre-recorders awesome
uh Paul taskelo says Epstein's former
Gulfstream G uh 5550 private jet is
currently available for Charter sold at
auction change registration and tail
number let me tell you more about it
look me up PJ Paul with Vault Aviation
Gulfstream I'm gonna avoid those from
now on like I've ever
blocked we have a plane for it's a
Gulfstream G5 uh 550 private General and
be like nah
you're being recorded on that not even
that I don't want to be in that plane I
don't care what they do you can't clean
that plane yeah we're talking about
turbo props earlier like hey bring that
one up you can scrub that thing with as
much with all the bleach in the world I
I don't think that thing is getting
clean nah but we it when we do fly we do
the lower uh lower cost ones I don't
give a shout out shout out to varajet
because it's like
the cost of flying first class to fly
private and so if we need to do a flight
for a show like where are we just in
Texas or whatever no you guys do Road
shows and then you hit the floor
sometimes yeah Florida we we had to like
we it's the only way to do it so and you
know this too A lot of people like well
will be like oh you're so rich and
elitist for flying private and it's like
if I didn't I couldn't do it I can't I
can't work 16 hours on a Friday and then
I've never been shy about that I'm like
you know what I grew up above a bar my
dad was a plumber my mom worked the
checkout counter and finest I busted my
ass man I tell people all the time like
I'm a capitalist I'm like it's Bernie
Sanders who's got a I'll fly wherever I
wanted I'm not apologizing for anything
well I want I want people to feel like
when they support us we're doing
everything we can with our resources to
win win the culture war and not being
frivolous with it but the reality is
like we're gonna fly if we fly down to
to do your show the only way that's
possible is if we get a private jet yeah
oh thank you there you go hook it up
Paula you got it it's like uh you know I
wake up at 8am I do the show then I work
throughout the day we're at the show at
11 p.m and then we have a plane waiting
for us we have to speed two to get on so
that I can get get to bed to wake up
this is what we had to do for uh uh the
valuetainment show I'm like yeah I want
to come down I want to come on the show
I want to talk about these things to an
audience Patrick Beth Davis yeah he's
amazing yeah he's all cat man he was on
my fox show a couple times he was
awesome he's a super good guest man in
order to do it we wrapped the show on
Friday hop in the car and go as fast as
we can to the local airport hop on a
private jet fly to Miami I get five
hours of sleep before I have to wake up
get cleaned up hop on a show and talk
for another four hours and then no day
off because I'm working again well I
told you during the break like for us it
doesn't make sense to do it otherwise
because if let's say we're doing a
certain amount of Revenue per show for
me to fly and get caught in an airport
and then miss two or three shows it
winds up becoming like the most
ridiculous money loser ever right so and
you can you know if you shop around you
get decent prices it's not as bad as
everybody thinks it is you know yeah
like the like I'm I'm we had some issues
with them early on that were really bad
but we gave him a chance and these are
like flying SUVs are super small but
basically you you get four adults and
two kids in there and it's like the cost
of first class so it's it's not as
expensive as people think it is but
granted this is not like a Gulf Stream
it's a little pod like a like a flying
SUV but I think
I mean look if you want to fly in
comfort you get your broker and you get
a King Air or whatever and you're gonna
go I don't have a jig I wouldn't buy I
don't fly enough like I fly a few times
a year that's it I mean that'll fly at
all I live in Florida like why would you
leave you know exactly I'm down there
all right let's see we got here Jake
says I'm fairly certain that right
around the time Epstein was picked up
Acosta said on camera that he was
approached and told Epstein was above
his pay grade and belonged to
intelligence
very interesting do you see that
reporter told me that this reporter is
totally legit too she was not messing
around when she told me that Itsy Bitsy
Spider production says System of a Down
is one of the most underrated bands of
all time yes from the overlapping voice
ranges to the operatic structure that
almost rival Queens
I don't think they're underrated yeah
there's bands in the world
rated probably an inaccurate use of the
term underwear yeah six months ago I
told you I didn't like them but hearing
toxicity like three days ago I was just
like dude chorus in Chop Suey is
probably one of the greatest things ever
put to music of all time right tell me
if you're heading banging at the end of
that man and you ain't doing it right
I'm sorry I listen to that still on the
plane all the headphones in blasting my
eardrums out that's so crazy it's like a
chromatic it's like the the math is all
weird like the rhythm is funky oh my God
but they are yes I love it man it's
awesome so unique see dub says hey Tim
and Dan I've been a long time listener
for uh to both your podcasts just hit
two years as a member of this month is
there any chances of combining forces
with a venture like Castro and parallel
economy
timcast.com proudly uses parallel
economy for our membership we love
having Tim cast we adore Timmy hey uh
listen I'll answer for myself I don't
want to speak for Tim but I have been
seeking Partnerships with Tim forever
because I believe in New Media Tim was a
Pioneer he was live streaming way before
me uh I I don't say that to kiss the
man's ass is no need for that we don't
do that here but um now man you're
you're a real Pioneer in this and if you
and me and two or three others and I
think you know this like there's
probably about and I don't say this with
any error pretension folks don't take it
the wrong way I'm just basing on pure
numbers me being in their live streaming
business and owning a chunk of Rumble
there are probably 10 people in the
United States right now who can do what
we do and bring the numbers it's just
the fact when it comes to political
podcasting on our side the libertarian
right side right to if me you and let's
say a few of those others combine forces
I mean we could start a behemoth Mammoth
of a company that would scare the living
out of just about everyone in the
political business I was just thinking
we should do a live event do some
collaborative well we got we we got big
news on the Miami event coming up which
I'm pretty sure I can just say
as of right now I it is my understanding
I am told
Matt Gates Don Jr and Patrick but David
are confirmed for our live show in Miami
so good when is that uh sometime in
October so I'm probably like right right
now our events people are probably
freaking out like what are you doing Tim
don't save right now and I was like but
when I told me that Matt Gates and Don
Jr definitely are going to be there live
on stage I was like can I can I say that
and they're like yeah it's confirmed Don
was here and I'm like we got you coming
down he's like yeah of course and I'm
like if you want to come down yeah I'm
in I'm committing right now let's do
this then you might be big enough we go
to Miami two days my daughter goes we
have like 800 seats my daughter goes to
University maybe maybe we should find
like a bigger venue 30 000 20 000
tickets
but that's the kind of New Media stuff
that makes me proud like working with
guys like yourself and I love that you
and I we just had this two-hour
conversation with your crew these guys
are awesome by the way like Greg you've
got a great team you guys are really
great man it's so easy to work with we
disagreed we agreed on some stuff and
yet we all agree on one thing like the
importance of New Media going forward we
have got to give people options man we
can't have like a monopoly on a cable
box anymore isn't it great that you can
have your position on abortion Ian
disagrees with you you talk we move we
have a conversation we're not liberal
lunatics that's why we're there what you
have to say too well that's maybe part
of why I'm able to disagree with people
absolutely care yeah like I think I
think we all are different positions on
the political Spectrum no one's like
clawing at their face yeah because we're
not cultists or anything like that I was
rubbing my head really hard earlier
let's grab uh some more Super chats
trying as many as we can I suppose yes
Norm says Rebirth of the militia act and
fund the local sheriff to be head of the
militia I don't know what the militia
Act is what is that one
I don't know what the militia Act is but
anything I mean if your sheriff is uh
elected it's a good idea to be Pro your
sheriff and make sure that the the guy
that gets elected is good so if there's
a guy that's running that's good like
help him out you know dude when the
abolish the police thing was going viral
I tweeted abolish the police and then
the next I responded with and bring back
militias
but the point of this tweet was to
exemplify what the left was asking for
with quote unquote community policing
that's what militia was do you do your
own Twitter by the way oh yeah yeah yeah
me too would you ever just say like some
Rando pisses you off on Twitter and you
like have to go at them for no reason
you ever do that yeah not really I mean
I might tweet at somebody I don't really
read the responses I spent so on
Saturday morning I went and I went and
rolled Jiu Jitsu and I messed up my my
knee dude you roll no no not much I try
to but I have a bad knee and I'm like a
white belt yeah I'm a purple belt yeah
man that's why I'm a mess look at my
elbow yeah that's both sides bro oh my
God yeah here's my show shoulder look at
this you got a lot of surgery look at
this they got scars everywhere Jesus
I've got like 20 scars on my chest
muscles like I kind of had to cut like
tumors all from Jiu Jitsu no no elbow
the shoulders from Jitsu my knee don't
work my left knee don't work and then uh
look this one was operated on two this
is you see my arms don't straighten yeah
that's true I got it I was I was I was
anyways I was hooked up on the on the
couch all weekend and the entire time
I'm just fighting the armies going at
commies all weekend screw the commies I
gotta read this one game Abel says Tim
what will happen at this point of no
return is Sodom and Gomorrah or most
likely Civil War no one can reason with
the left they've gone insane Sheamus
Coughlin said in the show that uh I I
don't want to ruin his quote because it
was brutal but he said something like if
God doesn't Smite the United States it
oh Sodom he owes Sodom and Gomorrah an
apology and I was like oh
he went for it on that one yeah I know
I'm like I don't know like I felt kind
of Blasphemous yeah
listen man I'm long on the United States
you know I am too I agree in such worse
places before people like to point out
that like uh your the average Empire
lasted like 250 years and they're like
oh the US has been around 248 or
whatever blah blah blah and it's like
hold on the U.S has been around 248. it
is it has not been an Empire the entire
time it has been an Empire since the end
of World War II and however if the
United States Empire collapses it means
the rebirth of the United States like
what we would refer to as the U.S
Imperial structure is not America yeah
it is a corporatist Neo liberal
neoconservative War Machine yeah and
that's exactly what Trump is opposing
exactly when Trump says bring the voters
back bring the manufacturing back he's
saying make America great again and you
have these these corporatist
establishment internationalist chills
who want war conflict military bases
that's not America that was never
America no so I don't care if the
American Empire Falls good we'll get
strong boaters we'll get shared
Community again we'll bring back jobs
there we go we talked about tool right
one great big festering neon distraction
yeah you know what you know what I keep
you all occupied learn to swim you know
what song really speaks to me is uh The
Sound of Silence
it may not be about today Simon and
Garfunkel yeah it may not be about today
but like those lyrics resonate still
when it's like they've added pray to the
neon God they made I'm like it's Twitter
it's like you could stick you could say
that song is about Twitter you know
people speaking without uh listening
people you know or whatever I'm like it
really does feel like whatever it is
they were looking at because I think
they were talking about the Free Speech
movement or something like that but I'm
like but that's when liberals were
actual liberals right now they're just
they're just straight they are
everything they accuse the right of
being yeah back in the 60s absolutely
right oh that definition of the word
liberals being the totals right now it's
Rush Limbaugh's fault because Rush
Limbaugh in the 90s made the term
liberal toxic he he beat the crap out of
the left and he I mean at the time it
probably wasn't you know it didn't
matter but now the word which has a
function and is actually valuable has
been totally annihilated dude that's the
thing is like it's it's not it's not the
Liberals it's it's the up the leftists
themselves say Liberals are the first to
go they're the ones who are the problems
it's not us all weekend I've been
sharing I have pictures of this graffiti
that says liberals get the bullet too or
they're scratch or liberal exactly the
uh scratch a liberal of fascist bleeds
the far left believes that Liberals are
fascists they see no light between
liberals to clarify far left the far
left thinks Liberals are liberals but
are the front line of fascists like they
defend the fascists every time yeah I
gotta read one last Super Chat from Star
War fan Tim I've watched for a long
while but never done it before but now
my best friend my dog Misty has been
diagnosed with cancer odds aren't good
I've had her for 13 years I figured
you'd sympathize after Mr bocus give my
best girl a shout out please shout out
to Misty you are a very good dog I'm
sorry to hear it man it's always it's
always sad but as I often say when it
comes to uh you know your dog being sick
and passing on or any pet that I just
view that that that emotion you get that
welling up is is your payment for all of
the good that your pet gave you you are
now expressing and giving back like it
all built up and was released and
everybody knows this is true that you
would never trade the time you spent
with your you with your dog your best
friend if it meant relieving that pain
you're feeling when they passed the pain
you feel when they pass is worth every
moment to know all of the joy and
happiness they brought you so I'm so I'm
sorry to hear that it's it's sad I I
wish you the best and uh for everybody
else thanks so much for hanging out
smash the like button subscribe to the
show share the show with your friends
we're going to have this uh pre-recorded
uncensored show come with a lot of
f-bombs from Dan
sorry about that so that's the
uncensored show it's a lot it was always
loud so check it out at timcast.com it
will be live in just a few moments you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me personally at timcast Dan
do you want to shout anything out yeah
you can check us out on Rumble
rumble.com bongino and I definitely want
to have you down uh for our show when we
build out our new studio I want to bring
the crew too these guys are money we'll
do a whole week of shows in in Florida
that'd be great man that would so kick
ass man you guys never gonna want to
leave it's beautiful yeah we were just
down there actually I played I was
playing poker at the Hard Rock Seminole
that was awesome dude how do you do
winter anymore man
I like winter inside years without
winner and I'm always telling Mom I'm
like what the hell how did we do winner
ever you know it's like 70 degrees and I
like snowboarding can't do that in
Florida yeah
when's your new studio coming up you
have a date hopefully by November
December so I'm definitely gonna hook
that up that would be awesome man we
would totally we should like simulcast
on your stream and we'd blow it up it'd
be like
I'm the lead singer of All That Remains
you can check me out on Twitter I am a
Phil that remains on Twitter I am Phil
that remains official on Instagram the
band is All That Remains you can check
them out on Spotify Apple music uh
the whole you know the nine to YouTube
all that stuff and you guys can follow
me at Ian crossland.net uh Ian cross on
everyone on social media I got my
YouTube channel Twitter follow me
subscribe to me Dan spectacular thank
you good to see you man that was awesome
it really was uh also shout out to Misty
the dog you're doing it yeah good luck
peace rest well yeah heal up see you
later and I am search.com uh yeah I'll
be in the chat today I'll be in the
comments rather um follow me everywhere
please uh I enjoy talking to you on
Twitter I enjoy arguing with you on
Twitter this is a good one thank you Dan
appreciate it thank you guys yeah it was
it was awesome I appreciate I can't wait
to do it again yeah absolutely down in
Florida all right everybody head over to
timcast.com become a member because
we're gonna have the uncensored special
bonus show coming up in just a few
moments on the front page and we will
see you all there